Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 15, Lua. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everybody. So, yeah, if you're wondering why the uh cadence of the show slowed down a little bit it's been a little bit more than two weeks people don't wonder anymore yeah
本节目由Host Tornado赞助。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和VPS解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第15期，Lua。Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好。所以，是的，如果你在纳闷为什么节目的更新节奏慢了一点，已经超过两周了，大家不用再纳闷了，是的。
uh it's because patrick and i were on vacation um patrick was in sunny beautiful florida no this was really hot oh really oh man already it's only may yeah but it was like really humid in 90 something oh man you don't realize how quickly and we're gonna sound really obnoxious jason just forewarning people because we're like oh sunny california and you know but you really do get used to it really fast and florida has amazing weather but i went back and i sweated the whole time yeah i remember when i went back to florida to visit my fam uh i remember my glasses fogging up like when i got off the airplane and like i couldn't see anything and it was like just so damp yes like it's so much more humid and hot oh yeah terrible now we said like whiny but that's okay i was in not humid uh alaska for a couple weeks and uh that was pretty
呃，这是因为帕特里克和我去度假了。嗯，帕特里克去了阳光明媚、美丽的佛罗里达。不，那里真的很热。哦，真的吗？天哪，才五月就已经这样了。是的，但那里湿度很大，气温有90多度（华氏度）。天哪，你没意识到适应得有多快。杰森，我们听起来会很讨厌，先给听众提个醒，因为我们就像“哦，阳光明媚的加州”，你知道的，但你确实很快就会习惯。佛罗里达的天气很棒，但我回去的时候一直在出汗。是的，我记得我回佛罗里达探亲时，呃，我记得我下飞机时眼镜都起雾了，什么都看不见，而且感觉非常潮湿。是的，那里潮湿闷热得多。哦，是的，太糟糕了。现在我们听起来像是在发牢骚，但没关系。我在不潮湿的阿拉斯加待了几周，呃，那真的很棒。
wild we uh we hiked all the way up to a glacier um a couple of guys got buried in the snow and we had to have we had snow shovels we had to dig them out um we were walking on these like uh snow shoes which are for people who don't know they're they look kind of like a beaver's tail they're like really like flat and wide and the idea is like you won't break through because you know the way it works is the snow keeps piling on top but the sun especially during the day sort of like heats up the snow and it creates kind of like a shell because it's like this water is heating and then cooling a lot and so you have this shell this shell that's harder than the snow itself. And underneath the shell, you have this soft snow. And so the snowshoes allow you to sort of walk on this shell
很狂野。我们徒步一直走到冰川，嗯，有几个人被雪埋住了，我们不得不拿雪铲把他们挖出来。我们当时穿着那种雪鞋，对于不知道的人来说，它们看起来有点像海狸的尾巴，非常平坦宽大。其原理是让你不会陷进去，因为雪会不断堆积在上面，但白天阳光会加热积雪，形成一种外壳，因为水在加热和冷却过程中反复循环，所以你得到了一层比雪本身更硬的外壳。而在外壳下面，是松软的雪。所以雪鞋让你可以在这层外壳上行走。
without having to, like, trudge through the snow, right? But if you do fall in, your snowshoes, like, break through. Then, like, you sink in, like, and people are sinking in, like, three, four feet in the snow. And then the snow the snow sort of like it's not like quicksand like you don't sink in it or anything but like you fall through the snow and then the snow like comes around you kind of and like entraps you and especially since you have the snowshoes that are like attached to your feet like you can't lift them up because there's just too much snow has like collapsed on you so um and this is somebody has to yes we did all this to go to a glacier and take a lot of pictures but you know the the the adventure was the fun of it i think they have helicopters for that yeah yeah we could have taken a helicopter instead we hiked it so uh our parents uh my in-laws came and uh they actually took the
而不用像在雪地里跋涉那样，对吧？但如果你掉进去了，你的雪鞋会穿透外壳。然后，就像，你会陷进去，人们陷进了三四英尺深的雪里。然后雪，雪会像……它不像流沙，你不会沉下去，但你会掉进雪里，然后雪会包围你，把你困住。特别是当你脚上还绑着雪鞋时，你根本抬不起脚，因为有太多的雪塌在你身上了。所以，嗯，有人必须……是的，我们做这一切就是为了去冰川拍很多照片，但你知道，冒险本身就是乐趣所在。我想他们有直升机可以去那里。是的，是的，我们本可以坐直升机的，但我们选择了徒步。所以，呃，我们的父母，我的岳父母来了，他们实际上是坐……
helicopter so we met they meet you out there okay yeah yeah we met them there and then they took the helicopter back and it was about i think it was like eight to ten miles um so it was quite a hike um and we were pretty exhausted and you know at some, at some one point, the, the tour group leader was like, you know, you've only done 50% cause we got to go back. So, um, those are the words you don't want to hear. Yeah. But some cool things about it. One, we saw some black bears. That was pretty cool. Um, we learned the difference between black bear, grizzly bear, and polar bear. So, uh, black bears are the least threatening. Um, and they pretty much run away as soon as they see you um grizzly bears and polar bears are like much more dangerous and brown bears
直升机去的，所以我们在那里会合。好的，是的，我们在那里会合，然后他们坐直升机回去了。全程大约有八到十英里，所以这是一次相当艰苦的徒步。我们精疲力竭，你知道，在某个时刻，导游说，你知道，你们只走了50%，因为我们还得回去。所以，嗯，那是你最不想听到的话。是的。但有一些很酷的事情。第一，我们看到了一些黑熊。那真的很酷。嗯，我们了解了黑熊、灰熊和北极熊的区别。所以，呃，黑熊威胁性最小。嗯，它们一看到你基本上就会跑掉。嗯，灰熊和北极熊要危险得多，棕熊……
are also pretty dangerous um what else oh the uh the tour guides made this awesome stuff they took like cocoa powder like like you'd used to make hot chocolate and tang and put it together and they made hot chocolate tang and it tasted like you know those orange chocolates like it's like a huge orange shaped chocolate oh yeah like slam it on the ground and it breaks into pieces you know it tasted like that it was really good yeah sure so so yeah i was kind of hiking in the wilderness and but we're back with luo survived yes we did it was pretty awesome i'll uh i have some pictures posted i'll share them with the meme hub um page so that anyone who's following the page will get to see the pictures of the hike or their programming throwdown page maybe too that's right the programming throwdown page
也相当危险。还有什么？哦，呃，导游做了很棒的东西。他们拿了可可粉，就像你用来做热巧克力的那种，还有Tang果珍，把它们混在一起，做成了热巧克力Tang。味道就像你知道的那种橙子巧克力，就是那种巨大的橙子形状的巧克力，哦，是的，像摔在地上就会碎成几块的那种。你知道，味道就像那样，真的很好吃。是的，当然。所以，是的，我当时在荒野里徒步，但我们回来了，带着Lua。活下来了，是的，我们做到了，这太棒了。我会，呃，我会贴一些照片，我会分享到Meme Hub页面，这样任何关注该页面的人都能看到徒步的照片，或者也许也可以发到Programming Throwdown页面。没错，Programming Throwdown页面。
what do i say you said main hub you have too many pages i have too many for real um i think i'm gonna add a third page now so it's gonna be just ridiculous uh-oh spoiler alert all right so the news of the week is uh facebook so uh i jason i think uses facebook some i have an account account, I think somewhere. All I know is Facebook keeps emailing me and saying, you have like 30 something friend requests. And I'm just like, I don't care. You should detect that. I haven't logged in in years. So I got one when it first came out. It's like the OAuth, you know, like, like some things now will let you log in using your Facebook ID. Like single sign on. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'll do that,
我该说什么？你说Main Hub，你有太多页面了。我真的有太多了。嗯，我想我现在要加第三个页面了，这简直太荒谬了。哦，剧透预警。好了，本周的新闻是，呃，Facebook。所以，呃，杰森，我想你偶尔会用Facebook。我有一个账户，我想在某个地方。我只知道Facebook一直在给我发邮件，说你有30多个好友请求。我只是觉得，我不在乎。你应该检测到这一点。我已经好几年没登录了。所以我刚出来的时候注册了一个。就像OAuth，你知道，现在有些东西会让你用Facebook ID登录。就像单点登录。是的，是的，是的。我会那样做，
but that's about all I use it for. So actually I'm interested how many of Facebook's 900 million users are doing that? Like only interaction or is it 900 million is like registered. And then I forget how many they claim are active, but how many of their active users, you know, are logging onto facebook.com being served ads,
但那基本上就是我用它的全部用途。所以实际上我很好奇Facebook的9亿用户中有多少人在这样做？是唯一的互动，还是说9亿只是注册用户。我忘了他们声称有多少活跃用户，但他们的活跃用户中有多少人，你知道，在登录facebook.com并被投放广告，
you know, and you know, interfacing with the content, being served ads you know and you know interfacing with the content how many are accessing it like on a mobile device where you don't get ads and then how many are just using it like you for you know just logging into other websites authenticating with stuff or just playing games yeah well i read an article that uh over a third of people just log on facebook to play zynga games so um yeah so farmville nobody admits to playing that game but i know there has to be a ton of people playing that game oh yeah totally there's got to be but you know i mean even just even if it's true and people aren't you know the whole wall post on the wall share with your friends if that's kind of like gone
你知道，并且，你知道，与内容互动。有多少人是在移动设备上访问它的，那里你看不到广告，还有多少人像你一样，你知道，只是登录其他网站进行身份验证，或者只是玩游戏。是的，嗯，我读过一篇文章，呃，超过三分之一的人登录Facebook只是为了玩Zynga游戏。所以，嗯，是的，Farmville，没人承认在玩那个游戏，但我知道肯定有很多人在玩。哦，是的，绝对有，肯定有。但你知道，我的意思是，即使这是真的，人们不是在，你知道，在墙上发帖，与朋友分享，如果那种东西已经像……
with the dodo, it's still pretty useful technology, you know, just being able to identify people and their relationships. And a lot of applications need something like that to be, you know, even better. But is it worth hundreds of billions of dollars? And that's the question that was asked at the end of last week. That's right. So Facebook IPO, their initial public offering and jason and i are not business majors we are not financial students oh yeah yeah let's put a disclaimer here you know we don't don't take this as stock market advice or anything like that this should not be construed as trading advice in any shape or form um but yeah so it was really weird we were watching it you know being in the tech industry.
渡渡鸟一样灭绝了，它仍然是相当有用的技术，你知道，能够识别人们及其关系。很多应用程序需要这样的东西来变得，你知道，更好。但它值数千亿美元吗？这就是上周末最后提出的问题。没错。所以Facebook IPO，他们的首次公开募股，杰森和我不是商科专业的，我们不是金融专业的学生。哦，是的，是的，让我们在这里加个免责声明，你知道，我们不，不要把这当作股市建议或类似的东西。这不应被解释为任何形式的交易建议。但，是的，所以这真的很奇怪，我们在看它，你知道，身处科技行业。
People at work were interested in this because it's a very, it hit mainstream, right? So even the morning news was covering Facebook's IPO and it being local to this area, the Silicon Valley that it was big news. And so people were watching it and it was just one of the weirdest things I've seen that people were just talking about it and then stuff just seemed to go terribly wrong. So when it first opened, it turns out afterwards I was trying to read because when I – I think it was LinkedIn or Groupon had IPO'd. I tried to watch it because I was curious what would happen. And it didn't open with the market.
工作中的人们对此很感兴趣，因为它已经进入了主流，对吧？所以连早间新闻都在报道Facebook的IPO，而且因为它发生在我们这个地区，硅谷，所以这是大新闻。所以人们都在关注它，这是我见过的最奇怪的事情之一，人们都在谈论它，然后事情似乎变得非常糟糕。所以当它刚开盘时，事后我试着去读，因为当——我想是LinkedIn或Groupon IPO时。我试着观察它，因为我很好奇会发生什么。它没有随市场开盘。
But this was expected and actually news reports said this was going to happen. But Facebook was supposed to start trading when the NASDAQ opened. They're going to trade on the NASDAQ or they are trading on the NASDAQ. But it turned out the NASDAQ had technical difficulties that delayed the start of trading for like almost three hours or two hours, two and a half hours, something like that. And so I read a little bit about it, trying to understand. And the best explanation I could kind of come across was that they, the IPO price, that very first price that it's going to start at is calculated by how many people kind of say, I'm going to buy shares at whatever price it opens at, right? So before the market opens, they put in an order with their broker. I don't care. Buy it right away.
但这在预料之中，实际上新闻报道也说会发生这种情况。但Facebook本应在纳斯达克开盘时开始交易。他们要在纳斯达克交易，或者他们正在纳斯达克交易。但事实证明，纳斯达克出现了技术故障，导致交易开始延迟了大约三个小时，或者两个小时，两个半小时，诸如此类。所以我读了一些相关内容，试图理解。我能找到的最好的解释是，他们，IPO价格，那个它将要开始的第一个价格，是根据有多少人说，我愿意以它开盘的任何价格购买股票来计算的，对吧？所以在市场开盘前，他们向经纪人下了订单。我不在乎。马上买入。
And those are matched, which is the whole purpose of the exchanges. So the New York Stock Exchange, NASDAQ, the Chicago Board of Exchange, these different markets, their whole point is matching somebody who wants to buy with somebody who wants to sell. So I don't want to derail you. You can table this, but I don't know the answer to this. What's the difference between the New York Stock Exchange and NASDAQ? Are they just two different people who do the same thing? The technologies behind them are kind of different,
这些订单是匹配的，这就是交易所的全部目的。所以纽约证券交易所、纳斯达克、芝加哥期权交易所，这些不同的市场，它们的全部意义在于匹配想要买入的人和想要卖出的人。所以我不想让你偏离主题。你可以把这个搁置，但我不知道这个问题的答案。纽约证券交易所和纳斯达克有什么区别？他们只是做同样事情的两个不同的人吗？它们背后的技术有点不同，
but essentially they're doing the same thing, which is at the base level, they're matching buyers and sellers for a given stock. So you know that if you want to trade, I'm trying to think of something that's on the New York Stock Exchange. I'm not good at this. Like AT&T, let's say, is on New York Stock Exchange.
但本质上它们做的是同一件事，即在基础层面，它们为给定的股票匹配买家和卖家。所以你知道，如果你想交易，我试着想一个在纽约证券交易所上市的东西。我不擅长这个。比如AT&T，假设，在纽约证券交易所。
Then you need to go there to trade it. Versus if you want to trade Facebook, it's on NASDAQ. So you need to go there to trade it. And your broker hides this. So your broker's job is to talk to somebody whose job is to talk to somebody whose job is to talk to somebody
那么你需要去那里交易它。而如果你想交易Facebook，它在纳斯达克。所以你需要去那里交易它。你的经纪人隐藏了这一点。所以你的经纪人的工作是与某人交谈，那个人的工作是与某人交谈，那个人的工作是与某人交谈，
whose job is to talk to the exchange. And in the old days, that used to meant like some person on the floor waving a piece of paper and screaming you know i have an order for five shares and he knows it's from some guy named jason gauchi but uh nobody else knows he's like i got five shares somebody else goes okay i'll sell you five shares you know um but now that's all done by computers and it's done at matching and at each level it goes through so like your broker the you know clearinghouse for your broker like these successive levels away from you um they can match people who also are using so like if you use fidelity let's say fidelity can match you against another fidelity customer um instead of having to go all the way out to the exchange because then fidelity makes more money that way because they don't have to
那个人的工作是与交易所交谈。在过去，这意味着像交易大厅里的某个人挥舞着一张纸大喊，你知道，我有一个五股的订单，他知道这是来自一个叫杰森·高奇的人，但呃，没有其他人知道。他就像，我有五股，另一个人说好的，我卖给你五股，你知道，嗯，但现在这一切都是由计算机完成的，是在匹配中完成的，并且在它经过的每一层，所以像你的经纪人，你知道，你经纪人的结算所，像这些离你越来越远的连续层，他们可以匹配那些也正在使用的人，所以如果你使用Fidelity，假设Fidelity可以让你与另一个Fidelity客户匹配，而不是必须一直去交易所，因为那样Fidelity赚的钱更多，因为他们不必
pay the exchange for this service it's almost like sort of like you could you could relate it to like electricity or water or something like yes you go to the nearest person who can give it you the supply yeah right right so okay so all this is like the nasdaq when it was opening had all of these orders because of course you know the people selling were in very small area, right? So Morgan Stanley, and I think a couple other investment banks. So they were the only people who were kind of giving sell orders to the NASDAQ. And then people across all other brokerages had buy orders. And so what NASDAQ needed to do, again, this is Patrick's understanding of reading a couple articles and trying to figure out what happened, is that they have to kind of figure out what that first price what it's going to open at is and so they have to go and
为这项服务支付交易所费用。这几乎就像，你可以把它比作电力或水之类的，是的，你去找最近能给你供应的人，对吧？所以，好的，所以这一切就像纳斯达克开盘时有所有这些订单，因为当然，你知道，卖方都在很小的区域内，对吧？所以摩根士丹利，我想还有其他几家投资银行。所以他们是唯一向纳斯达克提供卖单的人。然后所有其他经纪公司的客户都有买单。所以纳斯达克需要做的是，再次声明，这是帕特里克通过阅读几篇文章并试图弄清楚发生了什么而得出的理解，他们必须弄清楚第一个价格，它将以什么价格开盘，所以他们必须去，
match so jason wants to buy a thousand morgan stanley wants to sell ten thousand so okay i need to adjust the price to and fro do this and that there's limited you know they need to go through and basically have a a queue of all of the buys and sells match them against each other and determine what the final price at the end of all of that is and sells match them against each other and determine what the final price at the end of all of that is but what happened so if i understand right so the price of a stock so i guess so some people say i'm willing to buy but only for 30 and someone else says i'm willing to buy for up to 40 right and the person is saying like i'm willing to sell so obviously like the thing's going to try and match up the person who's willing to spend more
匹配。所以杰森想买一千股，摩根士丹利想卖一万股，所以好的，我需要调整价格来回做这个做那个，有限的，你知道，他们需要通过并基本上有一个所有买单和卖单的队列，将它们相互匹配，并确定所有这些结束时的最终价格。但发生了什么？所以如果我理解正确的话，股票的价格，所以我想，有些人说我愿意买，但只出30，另一个人说我愿意出到40，对吧？那个人说，我愿意卖，所以显然，这个东西会试图匹配那个愿意花更多钱的人。
so so it decides oh the price of the stock should be 40 because this guy's willing to spend 40 but then if if the guy who's willing to spend 40 isn't buying all the shares that are up for sale the guy who's spending 30 is buying half of them now the price is 35 something like that yeah so it's whatever the last price of a trade took place. So yes. So normally when a stock's not moving, it's because Jason says, I'll sell for 30 and I go, I only want to buy for 25. And so there's a gap of $5 between us. So an order doesn't take place. And then it's not until somebody else comes along, like maybe Jason says, okay, I'll sell you for 25. Then that's the last trade. So that's the price of stock 25. So basically there was all of these orders stacked up. And sometimes you can say, I don't care. Just buy me some. I don't care what the price is.
所以它决定，哦，股票价格应该是40，因为这家伙愿意花40。但如果那个愿意花40的人没有买下所有待售的股票，那个花30的人买了一半，现在价格是35，诸如此类。是的，所以它是最后一次交易发生的价格。所以是的。所以通常当股票不动时，是因为杰森说，我以30卖，我说，我只想以25买。所以我们之间有5美元的差距。所以订单没有成交。然后直到有其他人出现，比如杰森说，好吧，我以25卖给你。那么这就是最后一次交易。所以股票价格就是25。所以基本上所有这些订单都堆积在那里。有时你可以说，我不在乎。只要给我买一些。我不在乎价格是多少。
Right. And then what it'll do is it'll say, Jason's willing to sell at 30. So I'll buy all of his at 30. The next person's at 35. I'll buy all theirs at 35. You know, and then the person buying will get some at 30, some at 35, some at 40, whatever, you know, as it goes up. And so all of this has to take place to figure out what the price is going to be at open. And what my understanding was, is the way the NASDAQ software was written
对。然后它会说，杰森愿意以30卖。所以我以30买下他所有的。下一个人是35。我以35买下他们所有的。你知道，然后买方会以30买到一些，以35买到一些，以40买到一些，无论如何，你知道，随着价格上涨。所以所有这些都必须发生才能确定开盘价。而我的理解是，纳斯达克软件的编写方式，
is that they had kind of a unforeseen consequence where before the market opened, somebody modified their order said, Oh, I don't want to buy 1000 thousand I want to buy 500 you know and they could do this because the order hadn't been executed yet the trade hadn't taken place but when that happened when that queue had been filled up and you know millions and millions and millions of these you know orders were in there that when they got to one of these modifications they kind of had to go back to the start and go again because they had assumed, you know at you know 0.5 million that they had you know an order for this But now the order was actually something different and so they would need to kind of Unravel back to that point and kind of play it for it again
是他们有一种不可预见的后果，即在市场开盘前，有人修改了他们的订单，说，哦，我不想买1000股，我想买500股，你知道，他们可以这样做，因为订单还没有执行，交易还没有发生。但当这种情况发生时，当那个队列被填满，你知道，数以百万计的这些订单在里面时，当他们遇到这些修改之一时，他们不得不回到起点重新开始，因为他们假设，你知道，在0.5百万时，他们有一个订单。但现在订单实际上是不同的，所以他们需要回溯到那个点，然后重新运行。
And so they had this loop but then Because they had to go through all of these modification orders and it was taking a long time because there were so many many many Orders out there that when they came that caused a delay but then during the delay other people freaked out and go what's going on cancel my order you know modify my order too and so every time they would hit one of these i kind of had to start over again and so they just kind of ended up in this vicious cycle of delaying for hours trying to get through this mess and so eventually i guess they stopped that
所以他们有这个循环，但因为他们必须处理所有的修改订单，而且花费了很长时间，因为外面有太多太多的订单，当他们遇到这种情况时，导致了延迟。但在延迟期间，其他人惊慌失措，说怎么回事，取消我的订单，你知道，也修改我的订单。所以每次他们遇到这些，我不得不重新开始。所以他们最终陷入了这个恶性循环，延迟了几个小时试图解决这个烂摊子。所以最终我想他们停止了那个，
and like changed it so that it would ignore the modification orders or something but it caused a pretty big you know mess that this is a big brand name ipo facebook first day and then for like two hours nothing happened yeah and i mean you know what the article is sort of alluding to is that you know facebook before they went public they had you know i think it's goldman sachs i was trading these private shares so you could buy a piece of and so basically those people didn't have like all of these things happen to them or whatever and so they were able to sort of strategize and buy at the right time and get in on it sort of early and things like that and those people were probably all leaving, you know, right when it IPA, they were all selling.
并像改变了它，以便它会忽略修改订单之类的，但这造成了一个相当大的烂摊子，这是一个大品牌的IPO，Facebook的第一天，然后大约两个小时什么都没发生。是的，我的意思是，你知道文章所暗示的是，你知道，Facebook在上市之前，他们有，我想是高盛，在交易这些私人股票，所以你可以买一部分，所以基本上那些人没有遇到所有这些事情，或者其他什么，所以他们能够制定策略，在正确的时间买入，并提前进入，诸如此类。而那些人可能都在离开，你知道，就在IPO时，他们都在卖出。
Because, yeah, they bought in at like 20, right? Yeah, exactly. So that's the other thing is there's all these people trading beforehand. There was these issues that, you know, if you were just you or I, you'd have no idea what was going on. I only figured this out much later when I was reading about, you know, reports about what happened. And then the other thing that happened is the stock started to drop once that problem was fixed.
因为，是的，他们以20左右的价格买入，对吧？是的，完全正确。所以这是另一件事，有所有这些人在提前交易。存在这些问题，你知道，如果你只是你或我，你根本不知道发生了什么。我直到很久以后读到关于发生了什么的报告时才弄清楚。然后发生的另一件事是，一旦那个问题得到解决，股票就开始下跌。
And then it started to go back up. And you're like, whoa, it's going back up. Like, this is great. It's going to happen. The IPO pop. And then it turns out that that was the Morgan Stanley, the people doing the IPO. That was them like trying to pour all of their money into buying the shares to try to get the price to go back up and get people excited about it. But that only lasted so long. And then it dipped again. And then, you know, Monday, it dipped even more. And so now it's like on a slide downward, which is kind of bad. But all that to say that it was very complicated. And it turns out, if you didn't know what was going on, you probably were just going to get hurt. Yeah, I mean, I think that, you know, people's, you know, it's one of these things like it's always been like personally, I always like to invest.
然后它开始回升。你会想，哇，它在回升。这太棒了。它会发生的。IPO热潮。然后事实证明那是摩根士丹利，那些做IPO的人。那是他们试图投入所有资金购买股票，试图让价格回升并让人们对它感到兴奋。但这只持续了那么久。然后它又下跌了。然后，你知道，周一，它跌得更多。所以现在它处于下滑趋势，这有点糟糕。但所有这些都是说它非常复杂。事实证明，如果你不知道发生了什么，你很可能会受伤。是的，我的意思是，我认为，你知道，人们的，你知道，这是其中之一，就像它一直以来，我个人总是喜欢投资。
Like I've only invested a little bit, but I remember when I was in college, I had a little bit of money and I invested it in Apple. I bought like I think I bought like one share or something like that because you're like a broke college student. But it's like fun to invest in things that you believe in and sometimes you know if you believe in something uh it's sort of it's more than just like trading based on the statistics like you're trading based on like kind of like an educated insight and things like that it's like at the time i bought like one of the first i think i bought like the second gen ipod and i was like this thing is great this music player is awesome so i'll buy like one share or whatever. And, you know, it'd be fun to sort of do this with Facebook and say, look, Facebook, they're providing awesome technology.
就像我只投资了一点点，但我记得我在大学时，我有一点钱，我把它投资在苹果公司。我买了，我想我买了一股还是什么之类的，因为你就像一个破产的大学生。但投资你相信的东西很有趣，有时你知道，如果你相信某件事，呃，这不仅仅是基于统计数据的交易，就像你基于某种受过教育的洞察力进行交易。就像当时我买了，我想我买了第一批，我想我买了第二代iPod，我觉得这东西太棒了，这个音乐播放器太棒了，所以我买了一股还是什么。而且，你知道，用Facebook做这件事并说，看，Facebook，他们正在提供很棒的技术，这会很有趣。
And, you know, it's a way to sort of bring people together, et cetera, et cetera. But if you try to buy, at least right now, you're just going to end up getting caught up in so many people who are just playing this as a game and not, you know, as an and i think it's one of those things and you have to be honest with yourself if you're buying it for a long term don't look at it if you find yourself looking at it and thinking about it you're not in it for the long term yeah good point good point and so i i really don't know if like i mean i've so many people have said oh i have this great strategy and we're constantly like on the neuro evolution users group every week somebody's like oh i want to use this neuro evolution program to do stock market trading and just i mean if i give you one piece of advice from someone who's done a lot of ai in his life just don't bother you know i mean invest in companies
而且，你知道，这是一种将人们聚集在一起的方式，等等，等等。但如果你尝试购买，至少现在，你最终会被卷入太多只是把它当作游戏而不是，你知道，作为一种……而且我认为这是其中之一，你必须对自己诚实，如果你是为了长期投资而购买它，就不要看它。如果你发现自己在看它并思考它，你就不是为了长期投资。是的，好观点，好观点。所以我真的不知道，我的意思是，有这么多人说，哦，我有这个伟大的策略，我们经常在神经进化用户组上，每周都有人说，哦，我想用这个神经进化程序来进行股市交易，我的意思是，如果我给你一个来自一个一生中做过很多AI的人的建议，就别费心了，你知道，我的意思是，投资于公司，
that like you either believe in or you um you know you see they have a good future things like that and just just keep your money in them for a really long time and just treat it as as as uh sort of you know and if it goes up and down like what patrick's saying just ignore it and uh all of this like trying to like do all this gamey stuff and things i mean there's just so much uh infrastructure in place to do all of this like trying to like do all the gamey stuff and things i mean there's just so much uh infrastructure in place to do all of this like we went to one talk where this guy was doing what was it like nanosecond trading or something like that and they had written their own operating system to do this trading it's just insane so yeah this is just another case of that and if
你相信它们，或者你，你知道，看到它们有美好的未来，诸如此类，只要把你的钱放在里面很长一段时间，把它当作，作为一种，你知道，如果它涨涨跌跌，就像帕特里克说的，忽略它。所有这些试图做所有这些游戏化的东西，我的意思是，有太多的基础设施来做所有这些，就像我们去过一次讲座，那个人在做，那是什么，纳秒交易之类的，他们编写了自己的操作系统来进行这种交易，这简直太疯狂了。所以是的，这只是这种情况的另一个例子，如果你
you think i don't know like if you hear people saying they've got a system, they're probably not very successful and that's why they're trying to talk about it and sell something. Yeah, it's true. If they were really successful at like this system, they would just use the system until they didn't need money anymore.
认为，我不知道，如果你听到人们说他们有一套系统，他们可能不是很成功，这就是为什么他们试图谈论它并推销一些东西。是的，这是真的。如果他们真的在这样的系统上很成功，他们只会使用该系统，直到他们不再需要钱为止。
Yeah, yeah, exactly. Now that's not completely true. There's caveats to that. But for the most part, the people who are loudest about the stocks are typically the worst traders. People who are really good at it tend to be quiet and not say much yeah that's right and i mean it's it's um it's fun to fantasize about being like some kind of crazy like white hat hacker ai like super genius who like makes some program that
是的，是的，完全正确。现在这并不完全正确。这有警告。但大多数情况下，那些对股票声音最大的人通常是最糟糕的交易者。真正擅长的人往往很安静，不多说什么。是的，没错。我的意思是，幻想成为某种疯狂的白帽黑客AI超级天才，制造出某种程序，
you know makes a bunch of money but in reality there's just like massive massive hedge fund like based institutions that have like hundreds and hundreds of like postdocs and professor ex-professors things like that in ai who like do this kind of stuff and that's just like for them it's just like like owning a construction company or something they go in they put on their hard hat and they they just hack the stock market all day. So just one person, no matter what kind of talent or anything, is just not going to stand up to something like that. Yeah, there are always exceptions to the rules. But it's like anything.
你知道，赚一大笔钱，这很有趣，但实际上，有像巨大的对冲基金那样的机构，拥有数百名博士后和前教授，诸如此类的人工智能专家，他们做这种事情，这对他们来说就像拥有一家建筑公司一样，他们进去，戴上安全帽，整天黑进股市。所以一个人，无论有什么样的天赋或任何东西，都无法对抗那样的东西。是的，规则总有例外。但这就像任何事情一样。
You have to look at the odds, right? You always hear the kid who wants to be the NBA basketball player. And I feel bad for them, but I try to, you know, point out that's statistically unlikely. Yeah, that's right. But you don't know. I'm really good. I'm like, you're right. I don't know how good you are. But I mean, unless you know you're the best in your state, the best person you've ever played basketball against,
你必须看看赔率，对吧？你总是听到那个想成为NBA篮球运动员的孩子。我为他们感到难过，但我试着，你知道，指出这在统计学上是不太可能的。是的，没错。但你不知道。我真的很棒。我就像，你是对的。我不知道你有多棒。但我的意思是，除非你知道你是你们州最好的，你打过篮球的最好的对手，
you're not making it to the NBA. Yeah, and I mean, and again, that's a perfect example. The people who make it to the NBA, by and large, are people who played in like amateur athletic union by and large are people who played in like amateur athletic union played in high school played in college and by the time they get ready to enter the nba they have like this whole history and they have like a i don't want to say like an entourage that's not the right word but but they have like connections they know the the the ins and outs they like they know how the play is supposed to be run. They can go to the coach and they speak the same language.
你是不可能进入NBA的。是的，我的意思是，再一次，这是一个完美的例子。进入NBA的人，总的来说，是那些在业余体育联盟中打球的人，在高中打球，在大学打球，当他们准备进入NBA时，他们有这样的整个历史，他们有，我不想说像随从，那不是正确的词，但他们有联系，他们知道来龙去脉，他们知道比赛应该怎么打。他们可以去找教练，他们说同样的语言。
There's all this infrastructure, social and physical infrastructure in place already. You couldn't take somebody who has just incredible natural talent and expect them to make the NBA without going through these phases. Well, our second news story, not to dwell on finance stuff forever this is a programming podcast uh totally uh twitter uh has changed they wanted to do better at recommending who to follow what to do you know what things of interest um and so they're going
所有这些基础设施，社会和物理基础设施已经到位。你不能带一个仅仅有不可思议的天赋的人，指望他们不经过这些阶段就能进入NBA。好吧，我们的第二个新闻故事，不要永远纠结于金融问题，这是一个编程播客，完全是，呃，Twitter，已经改变了，他们想在推荐关注谁、做什么、你知道什么感兴趣的事情方面做得更好，所以他们要
to start kind of i i guess it's going to be opt out but they want to start doing more tracking of their users to figure out what they're doing, to figure out what they're interested in so they can provide better recommendations. And of course, as always, people are upset. You know, Twitter wants to track you. They're invading your privacy. true. It comes down to the thing I want to bring up with this article is this problem, this walk that these companies have to do to straddle making something that's useful to you and respecting your privacy. Some things you can provide in a perfectly anonymous manner, but it is actually what they're trying to do. I feel it will be better if they track me, but them tracking me means they have
开始，我猜这将是选择退出，但他们想开始对用户进行更多的跟踪，以弄清楚他们在做什么，弄清楚他们对什么感兴趣，这样他们就能提供更好的推荐。当然，一如既往，人们很生气。你知道，Twitter想跟踪你。他们在侵犯你的隐私。真的。归根结底，我想用这篇文章提出的问题是这个问题，这些公司必须跨越的鸿沟，即制造对你有用的东西和尊重你的隐私。有些东西你可以以完全匿名的方式提供，但这实际上是他们试图做的。我觉得如果他们跟踪我会更好，但他们跟踪我意味着他们有
information about me that I don't necessarily want them to have. And so how do I make that decision? How do they make that decision? How does somebody who doesn't understand any of these things make that decision? It's very complicated. And it's something more and more that I think Facebook, Google, Twitter, all these people are having to address. How do they provide tailored, personalized, useful results to their users without invading their privacy too much. Yeah, definitely. I mean, that's a huge, huge concern, right, for these companies. Because, like, let's say Twitter makes this and there's a hole in it and somehow advertisers get access to, like, your interests at a very deep level. And let's say they get access to your address even and things like that. I mean this this sounds
关于我的信息，我不一定想让他们拥有。那么我该如何做出那个决定？他们该如何做出那个决定？一个不了解任何这些事情的人该如何做出那个决定？这非常复杂。而且我认为Facebook、Google、Twitter，所有这些人越来越多地必须解决这个问题。他们如何在不侵犯隐私太多的情况下，为用户提供量身定制的、个性化的、有用的结果。是的，绝对。我的意思是，这对这些公司来说是一个巨大的、巨大的担忧，对吧？因为，假设Twitter制造了这个，里面有一个漏洞，不知何故广告商可以以非常深入的程度访问你的兴趣。假设他们甚至可以访问你的地址之类的。我的意思是这听起来
really far-fetched but i actually went to uh and this is real i went to a uh uh what is the word a conference where somebody was giving a talk and they actually using twitter posts or tweets i guess they were able to determine someone's location of where they lived with like remarkable accuracy. And they use the, so Carnegie Mellon comes up, has a Twitter like data set. So I don't really know much about how it works. It's somehow anonymized, but basically it's like a, it's like a slice of, of all of Twitter's data. And so researchers can use this information that's been scrubbed somehow to uh you know do various experiments and things like that and the kind of things that people can deduce is just shocking well i saw one that it was just by the dialect like the words you use
真的很牵强，但我实际上去了一个，这是真的，我去了一个，呃，呃，那个词是什么，会议，有人在演讲，他们实际上使用Twitter帖子或推文，我猜，他们能够以惊人的准确度确定某人居住的位置。他们使用，所以卡内基梅隆大学提出了一个Twitter数据集。所以我不太了解它是如何工作的。它以某种方式匿名化了，但基本上它就像，它就像Twitter所有数据的一小部分。所以研究人员可以使用这些以某种方式清理过的信息来，呃，你知道，做各种实验之类的，人们能推断出的事情简直令人震惊。好吧，我看到一个，仅仅通过方言，你使用的词
are regional so you can identify where somebody is in the country by just the words they choose to use even in their 140 character tweets yeah yeah that's a big part of it and they also do um it's it's kind of it's based on your connectivity like people you're connected to because you think about this right like if if you know if they could figure out for half of the people then they could just use the connectivity like who's friends with who who's following who to figure out the other half you know so if one person says oh i went and saw the giants i walked to the giants game today then you know it could use that phrase to figure out well they must be really close if they walked and so everyone they're following you know is statistically
是区域性的，所以你可以通过他们选择使用的词来识别某人在国家的什么位置，即使在他们140个字符的推文中。是的，是的，这是很大一部分。他们还做，嗯，它是基于你的连接性，就像你连接的人，因为你考虑一下这个，对吧？如果，如果他们能为一半的人弄清楚，那么他们就可以利用连接性，谁和谁是朋友，谁在关注谁，来弄清楚另一半。你知道，如果一个人说，哦，我今天去看了巨人队的比赛，我走到巨人队比赛现场，那么你知道，它可以使用那个短语来弄清楚，好吧，如果他们走路的话，他们一定离得很近，所以他们关注的每个人，你知道，在统计学上
likely to also be in san francisco etc etc, et cetera. And they can, you know, build all these inferences and layer them on top of each other. So, yeah, I mean, there's, the short of it is there's an incredible amount of thing, of interesting things that they can deduce from your information. And they can use that to sort of provide, like, really, like, targeted-based, you know, whether it's advertising or whether it's giving you information, whether it's assisting you with your searches or there's tons of things that Twitter can do with this data. But yeah, at some point it crosses the line of being creepy.
也可能在旧金山，等等，等等。他们可以，你知道，建立所有这些推论并将它们叠加在一起。所以，是的，我的意思是，简而言之，他们可以从你的信息中推断出令人难以置信的有趣的事情。他们可以使用它来提供，比如，真正地，比如，基于目标的，你知道，无论是广告，还是给你信息，无论是协助你搜索，还是Twitter可以用这些数据做很多事情。但是的，在某个时候，它越过了令人毛骨悚然的界限。
And that line is different for each person. That's what makes it so difficult. Or not even the creepy, but just like you said, the risk of somebody leaking out information you didn't want leaked out. Yeah, yeah. Both of those are just like you said the risk of somebody leaking out information you didn't want leaked out yeah yeah both of those are just really dangerous um like that was one of the big things with uh oh there was some social game i can't remember what it was called but it was basically like a you you managed an aquarium and like there's different fish and your friends had fish
而那条界限对每个人来说都是不同的。这就是让它变得如此困难的原因。或者甚至不是令人毛骨悚然，而只是像你说的，有人泄露你不想泄露的信息的风险。是的，是的，两者都是，就像你说的，有人泄露你不想泄露的信息的风险。是的，是的，两者都真的很危险。嗯，就像那是关于，呃，哦，有一个社交游戏，我不记得它叫什么了，但它基本上就像你管理一个水族馆，就像有不同的鱼，你的朋友有鱼
or something and they were doing pretty good it was like a startup and they had like a few million users and people were buying fish and things like that then they did something which was kind of sketchy like i can't remember what it was oh it's like somehow they'd figure out where you lived based on like your facebook posts and things like that then they try and like put you in an aquarium with other people who live near you and and the whole thing died like people got freaked out and every like a bunch of people canceled their account and uh that startup went under like almost immediately wow yes it's like a huge concern is is you know walking this line between oh this is really cool and this is totally creepy well onto something completely different uh i read this
或者其他什么，他们做得相当不错，它就像一个初创公司，他们有几百万用户，人们在买鱼之类的，然后他们做了一些有点可疑的事情，就像我不记得是什么了，哦，就像他们不知何故根据你的Facebook帖子之类的弄清楚了你住在哪里，然后他们试图把你和一个住在你附近的人放在一个水族馆里，然后整个事情就死了，人们被吓坏了，每个人，一大群人取消了他们的账户，那个初创公司几乎立即倒闭了。哇，是的，这就像一个巨大的担忧，是，你知道，走在这条线之间，哦，这真的很酷，这完全令人毛骨悚然。好吧，转到完全不同的事情，呃，我读了这篇
article that was i thought was really cool we've talked in the past about microcontrollers and embedded programming and here's a guy um we have a link in the show notes but who is programming controlling his arduino which is one of these uh small embedded microcontrollers uh with javascript and i thought that was really cool how somebody had a passion. They really want to write stuff in JavaScript. And so they actually figured out how to use JavaScript to do something you wouldn't expect. Yeah, yeah, totally. That's pretty awesome.
文章，我觉得真的很酷。我们过去谈论过微控制器和嵌入式编程，这里有一个人，嗯，我们在节目笔记中有一个链接，但他正在用JavaScript编程控制他的Arduino，这是这些小型嵌入式微控制器之一，我觉得这真的很酷，有人有热情。他们真的想用JavaScript写东西。所以他们实际上弄清楚了如何使用JavaScript做一些你意想不到的事情。是的，是的，完全正确。这太棒了。
That's a benefit between, you know, I mean, remember, like, it wasn't too long ago where compilers were totally closed source, locked down, and it's like you would you would take your c or c++ code and you'd build it using gcc uh you know and then you'd build it with the intel compiler and you'd build it with like this other compiler and all these you know it'd be so much faster and things like that and it's just nice to see that like the whole industry has really matured and all of these tools are just totally open and accessible. And if you want to do something crazy like this, like recompile the JavaScript virtual machine for Arduino, you have the freedom to do it.
这是，你知道，我的意思是，记住，就像，不久前编译器还是完全闭源的，锁定的，就像你会拿你的C或C++代码，你会使用GCC构建它，你知道，然后你会用英特尔编译器构建它，你会用像其他编译器构建它，所有这些，你知道，它会快得多，诸如此类，看到整个行业真的成熟了，所有这些工具都是完全开放和可访问的，这很好。如果你想做一些像这样疯狂的事情，比如为Arduino重新编译JavaScript虚拟机，你有自由去做。
Yeah. So, well, so I guess the way this actually worked is there's Node.js, which is C++ JavaScript interpreter that actually, guess powers Chrome is the same one so V8 is that what it's called I believe? That's right. Yeah and so in there because of the C++ they could basically create a crafted interface between the JavaScript portion and the C++ portion which had
是的。所以，好吧，所以我猜这实际上工作的方式是Node.js，它是C++ JavaScript解释器，实际上，我猜驱动Chrome的是同一个，所以V8是它叫什么吗？我相信是这样。是的，所以在那里，因为C++，他们基本上可以在JavaScript部分和C++部分之间创建一个精心设计的接口，它有
access to the serial ports so you could control commands out the serial ports and then with a little bit of fiddling and magic wizardry we'll call it on the serial commands that got sent across you could send across special ones that were interpreted on the Arduino side to blink a light or read a sensor or whatever ah nice so that's awesome it's pretty cool.
访问串口，这样你就可以通过串口发送控制指令，然后通过一点点小技巧和我们称之为“魔法”的操作，对发送的串口指令进行处理，你可以发送特殊的指令，让 Arduino 端去闪烁灯光、读取传感器或做其他任何事情。啊，不错，那太棒了，这真的很酷。
It's kind of crazy to see what lengths people will go to to use something that isn't necessarily the first closest tool for the job that you would expect. So people would normally say, like, oh, CRC++. But here's a guy who took JavaScript, maybe one of the least likely ones you would say, and got that to work as well because that's what he liked. Yeah, isn't that crazy how popular javascript is becoming like it just blows my mind there's a there's there's node.js which is pretty awesome
看到人们为了使用某种工具而做出如此大的努力，即使它未必是完成这项工作最直接、最合适的工具，这真是令人疯狂。通常人们会说，哦，用 C 或 C++。但这里有个人用了 JavaScript，这可能是你最不会想到的语言之一，但他让它成功运行了，因为那是他喜欢的。是啊，JavaScript 变得如此流行，这难道不疯狂吗？这简直让我大开眼界，还有 Node.js，它非常棒。
then there's um oh there's i'm totally drawing blank oh oh the android um what is it called i think it's called like mojave or something but basically the thing is you write uh javascript code and then it turns your javascript code into either like uh or it has like it's a virtual machine written in java to run your code on the android and it also has one written in objective c let me see if i can find this okay um but yeah basically so people are writing native, like, phone code in JavaScript. And then it's, like, then they're just compiling it or they're running it on all the phones. So they don't have to, like, write their code in Java, write another copy for the iPhone, write another copy for the Windows phone, et cetera, et cetera.
然后还有，哦，我完全想不起来了，哦，那个 Android 的……它叫什么来着？我想它叫 Mojave 之类的，但基本上，你可以编写 JavaScript 代码，然后它会把你的 JavaScript 代码转换成……或者说它有一个用 Java 编写的虚拟机来在 Android 上运行你的代码，它还有一个用 Objective-C 编写的虚拟机。让我看看能不能找到它。好吧，但基本上，人们正在用 JavaScript 编写原生的手机代码。然后他们只是编译它，或者直接在所有手机上运行它。所以他们不必用 Java 写一份代码，再为 iPhone 写一份，再为 Windows Phone 写一份，等等等等。
Oh, cool. Yeah, yeah, JavaScript is becoming extremely popular. I mean, it already was popular, but it's just growing at an alarming rate. Well, on a similar topic to controlling real-world things through your computer, I guess this is another dream of science fiction, but I read an article about people controlling robots
哦，酷。是啊，是啊，JavaScript 变得非常流行。我的意思是，它本来就很流行，但它正以惊人的速度增长。嗯，说到通过电脑控制现实世界的事物，我想这是科幻小说的另一个梦想，但我读过一篇文章，关于人们控制机器人。
with their brain. And so this one was actually, I think she had this a lady who had a brain implant was able to get a robotic arm to bring her a cup of coffee and actually tip it into her mouth so she could drink some um why use a very steaming hot beverage i guess just to show how confident you were in your system but that seems dangerous to me but uh it is a amazing feat and there's a lot of problems and they said that they had to do it multiple times and like i think they said it worked like four out of the five times or
用他们的大脑。所以这个案例，我想是一位女士，她植入了脑部芯片，能够让机械臂给她端来一杯咖啡，并实际倾斜杯子送到她嘴边，这样她就能喝到一些……为什么要用非常烫的饮料呢？我想只是为了展示你对系统的信心，但这对我来说似乎很危险，但这是一个了不起的壮举。而且有很多问题，他们说他们必须多次尝试，我想他们说五次里成功了四次，或者
three out of the five times or something so there's time she was burned horribly oh no no i think she just you know dropped it or tipped it over or whatever um but yeah so it's kind of cool this brain computer interface is for paralyzed people and that's i mean that's just amazing that what it might be able to do to help those people and then one day you know maybe even the rest of us to be able to do that is like i said a dream of science fiction and young kids everywhere yeah i mean everyone should watch this video it's amazing so how does that work is it is it based off like i mean it's not literally like it's not hasn't punctured her skin right yeah no no no this one has so what they do is they okay i think it's a
五次里成功了三次之类的，所以有几次她被烫得很惨。哦不，不，我想她只是，你知道，把它掉在地上了，或者把它打翻了之类的。但确实，这很酷，这种脑机接口是为瘫痪人士准备的，我的意思是，这太神奇了，它可能对帮助这些人做些什么，也许有一天，你知道，甚至我们其他人也能做到这一点，就像我说的，这是科幻小说的梦想，也是各地年轻孩子的梦想。是啊，我的意思是每个人都应该看这个视频，太神奇了。那么它是如何工作的呢？它是基于……我的意思是，它不是真的……它没有刺穿她的皮肤，对吧？是啊，不，不，这个有。所以他们做的是，他们……好吧，我想是一个
sensor maybe like the size of a grain of rice something really small and they bury it in a certain portion of the brain so they kind of like drill a hole in your brain and put this long needle with something on the end of it into this certain point and then there's a bunch of little probes on the end is what i understand and they measure the electrical spikes in the area of your brain so neurons when they fire and talk to each other in your brain when your brain has activity those emit emi signals electromagnetic signals um and so when or i guess just em signals um i didn't get extra letters and the they're able to pick those up you know measure those um and see that your brain has activity but at first it just kind of seems random because you have no idea what neurons you're next to or what exactly they're for what they're doing but then you, kind of like a child learns, you learn that, oh, when I think of the
传感器，可能像米粒那么大，非常小，他们把它埋在大脑的某个特定部位，所以他们会在你的大脑上钻个孔，把这根长针，末端带着东西，插进这个特定的点，据我所知，末端有一堆小探针，它们测量大脑该区域的电脉冲。所以当神经元在大脑中放电并相互交流时，当你的大脑有活动时，它们会发出 EMI 信号，电磁信号，嗯，所以当……或者我想只是电磁信号，我没多加字母，他们能够捕捉到这些，你知道，测量它们，并看到你的大脑有活动，但起初它看起来很随机，因为你不知道你旁边是哪些神经元，或者它们到底是做什么的，它们在干什么，但后来，就像孩子学习一样，你学会了，哦，当我想到
color green and smell the color coffee and try to move my left finger, you know, my left index finger, like I noticed that the arm kind of does this wiggle motion. And so then over time, your brain kind of learns to think in a certain way to be able to control it. And what it is, is just these electrodes picking up the signals and detecting that your brain is emitting a certain pattern. And then they interpret that pattern as, you know, move left or move right, move up, move down. Ah, that's amazing.
绿色，闻到咖啡的味道，并试图移动我的左手指，你知道，我的左食指，我注意到手臂会做出这种摆动的动作。所以随着时间的推移，你的大脑会学会以某种方式思考，从而能够控制它。而它实际上只是这些电极捕捉信号，并检测到你的大脑正在发出某种模式。然后他们将该模式解释为，你知道，向左移或向右移，向上移，向下移。啊，那太神奇了。
But this one actually gets implanted in your brain, the one they're using. Yeah, because we've seen one where, we were looking into one a while ago. Right, that goes on the outside. Yeah, yeah, but that one had mixed results but it looks like this one is much more fidelity yes because it is the skull blocks a lot of that uh electromagnetic signal yeah that makes sense makes sense so cool so yeah the next
但这个确实是植入到你的大脑里的，他们用的那个。是啊，因为我们见过一个，我们前阵子研究过一个。对，那个是戴在外部的。是啊，是啊，但那个效果参差不齐，但看起来这个保真度高得多。是的，因为头骨阻挡了很多那种电磁信号。是啊，这说得通，说得通。太酷了，所以，下一个
article we have is why airplane bathrooms have ashtrays and i assume it's not just because the airplane was built before smoking was banned no so that's the shocking thing and even new airplanes that are built now have ashtrays with no smoking symbols on them wait they have the ashtrays themselves have no smoking symbol yeah you should see that you should see some of the pictures this article there's literally an ashtray with a with a big no smoking on it. And so you think to yourself, well, this is like some kind of like corporate, you know, bureaucracy kind of thing. Like somebody didn't do their paperwork or something and now all the airplanes have to have, you know. But no, it's actually a result of something that was quite tragic.
我们有的文章是为什么飞机厕所里有烟灰缸，我假设不仅仅是因为飞机是在禁止吸烟之前制造的。不，这就是令人震惊的地方，即使是现在制造的新飞机也有烟灰缸，上面还有禁止吸烟的标志。等等，它们有烟灰缸本身，上面有禁止吸烟的标志？是啊，你应该看看那个，你应该看看这篇文章里的一些图片，真的有一个烟灰缸，上面有一个大大的禁止吸烟标志。所以你会想，好吧，这就像某种企业官僚主义之类的东西。就像有人没做好文书工作之类的，现在所有的飞机都必须有，你知道。但不是，这实际上是一起相当悲惨的事件的结果。
Somebody smoked, was smoking on an airplane while it was in flight. And, you know, there's nowhere for them to put their cigarette because because smoking had been banned so they flushed the cigarette down the toilet and this this seems like very bizarre to me that's what i'm about to say but somehow that caused the plane to crash like almost everybody died like i don't understand how flushing a cigarette down toilet can do that maybe they maybe they didn't flush it down the toilet because it said it was it was like poorly disposed of maybe they just put it in a trash can oh maybe they put it in where you put your paper towels oh yeah that makes much more sense but yeah basically somebody did that and the plane crashed and everybody died and so um so so they they decided that they're going to put ashtrays on
有人在飞机飞行时吸烟。而且，你知道，他们没地方扔烟头，因为吸烟已经被禁止了，所以他们把烟头冲进了马桶。这对我来说听起来非常离奇，这就是我正要说的，但不知何故这导致了飞机坠毁，几乎所有人都死了。我不明白把烟头冲进马桶怎么会那样，也许他们……也许他们没有把它冲进马桶，因为它说它是被不当处理的，也许他们只是把它放进了垃圾桶。哦，也许他们把它放进了放纸巾的地方。哦，是啊，那更有道理。但基本上，有人那样做了，飞机坠毁了，所有人都死了，所以……所以他们决定在
planes uh mandatory and the idea is you know that where they're getting at here is yes you know in a perfect world you would you would have the no smoking symbol you know above their head you have the smoke no smoking on the entry of the door the no smoking all over the bathroom the signs everywhere and people just wouldn't smoke right but the reality is that you know eventually No smoking on the entry of the door, no smoking all over the bathroom, the signs everywhere. And people just wouldn't smoke, right? But the reality is that, you know, eventually you have to come to terms with that, you know, this is an addiction and that people, you know, their tendency. Like if you did a use case study or something, you'd find that people just have to smoke, right? And there's like one in a thousand or however many that just have to do it and so by putting in the ashtrays they're saying well look you know you know if somebody has to smoke if they're going to just like if they're willing to take
飞机上强制安装烟灰缸，他们的想法是，你知道，他们在这里要表达的是，是的，你知道，在一个完美的世界里，你会……在他们的头顶上方会有禁止吸烟的标志，在入口门上有禁止吸烟标志，厕所里到处都是禁止吸烟标志，到处都是标志，人们就不会吸烟了，对吧？但现实是，你知道，最终你必须接受这一点，你知道，这是一种成瘾，人们，你知道，他们的倾向。就像如果你做了一个用例研究之类的，你会发现人们就是忍不住要吸烟，对吧？而且有一千分之一或者无论多少人就是忍不住要这样做，所以通过安装烟灰缸，他们是在说，好吧，看，你知道，如果有人非要吸烟，如果他们愿意承担
that risk of the fine and the alarm detector going off and them going jail and everything and they're still going to do it then like we have to have a way for them to do it without blowing up the plane and then it goes from there into like a little bit of hyperbole but it's actually really interesting on uh sort of like how do you design for human nature and it gives like a doorknob as an example um so i thought it was pretty cool so definitely give that article a looki yeah well um so it did say that the airline crashed because the smoke so however it was improperly disposed of it filled the cabin with smoke and a bunch of people died from smoke inhalation because there's no like when just pressurized and everything there's nowhere for the smoke to go oh wow and so it just keeps building in the cabin oh so it's probably what
罚款和警报器响起的风险，以及他们去坐牢等等，而他们仍然要这样做，那么我们必须有一种方法让他们在不炸毁飞机的情况下这样做。然后它从那里变成了一点夸张，但它实际上非常有趣，关于……你如何为人类本性进行设计，它给出了一个门把手作为例子，所以我认为这很酷，所以一定要看看那篇文章。是啊，嗯，所以它确实说飞机坠毁是因为烟雾，所以无论它是如何被不当处理的，它让机舱充满了烟雾，很多人死于吸烟，因为没有……当加压和一切的时候，烟雾无处可去。哦，哇，所以它就在机舱里不断积聚。哦，所以这可能就是
you're saying then he put it in where the paper towels are and it causes a huge fire it was in 1973 so it was actually a while ago yeah yeah definitely so all right is it that time it's time tool of the bi-week yeah all right you're up first man all right so my tool of the bi-week it's actually two tools wait wait wait wait wait wait i know that's not fair i'm breaking the rule man but now you're twice as awesome as me this week we've been we've been on vacation i want to come back you know all all pistons firing so these the you're the you're going to only use one of these tools though depending on what language you're programming in um the tools are berkeley db and jdbm3 and basically what these are let's say you know let's say you
你说的，然后他把它放进了放纸巾的地方，导致了一场大火。那是在 1973 年，所以实际上是很久以前了。是啊，是啊，绝对是。好吧，是那个时间了吗？是双周工具的时间了。是啊，好吧，你先来，伙计。好吧，所以我的双周工具，实际上是两个工具。等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，我知道那不公平，我打破了规则，伙计。但现在你这周比我厉害两倍了。我们一直在度假，我想回来，你知道，火力全开。所以这些……你只会使用其中一个工具，取决于你用什么语言编程。嗯，这些工具是 Berkeley DB 和 JDBM3，基本上它们是什么，让我们说，你知道，让我们说你
want to store a lot of data so what you want is a database right but when most people think of a database they think of like mysql let's say so you know here you are let's say i'm writing some program to i don't know just like count the number of times someone visits my site and just store it on disk right so if i do mysql i have to set up a mysql server i have to you know like have that service running on a machine somewhere i have to open that port because mysql communicates through tcp i have to write some mysql client which uses the tcp. I have to write some MySQL client, which uses the TCP socket. I have to serialize all my data and take my data,
想要存储大量数据，所以你想要的是一个数据库，对吧？但当大多数人想到数据库时，他们会想到 MySQL 之类的。所以，你知道，在这里，假设我正在写一个程序来，我不知道，只是像计算某人访问我网站的次数，并把它存储在磁盘上，对吧？所以如果我用 MySQL，我必须设置一个 MySQL 服务器，我必须，你知道，让那个服务在某台机器上运行，我必须打开那个端口，因为 MySQL 通过 TCP 通信。我必须编写一些使用 TCP 套接字的 MySQL 客户端。我必须序列化我所有的数据，并获取我的数据，
which might be a bunch of classes and functions, things like that, and turn it into MySQL tables. I have to create the schema. There's so much overhead, right? You can avoid some of that by using SQLite, but maybe that's for another week. Oh, yeah, yeah.
这可能是一堆类和函数之类的东西，然后把它变成 MySQL 表。我必须创建模式。开销太大了，对吧？你可以通过使用 SQLite 避免其中一些，但也许那是下周的事了。哦，是啊，是啊。
Well, even with SQLite, you have to do a lot of that. Yeah, but you still have some of those problems, yeah. You have to create the tables. Sorry, not to rain on your parade. So, the simplest thing, the simplest database that I can think of, at least, is a key value
嗯，即使使用 SQLite，你也必须做很多那样的操作。是啊，但你仍然有一些那些问题，是啊。你必须创建表。抱歉，不是要泼你冷水。所以，最简单的事情，我能想到的最简单的数据库，至少，是一个键值
pair, right? So, basically, you just have a list of keys and a hash table, basically, but on disk. And so that's exactly what Berkeley DB is. It's just a simple hash table that persists the disk. And you can put in keys, you can put in key value pairs, and then later on you can search for the key and you can get the value.
对，对吧？所以，基本上，你只是有一个键列表和一个哈希表，基本上，但在磁盘上。而这正是 Berkeley DB。它只是一个简单的哈希表，持久化到磁盘。你可以放入键，你可以放入键值对，然后稍后你可以搜索键并获取值。
And it does some clever caching. But if you fall through the cache, cache you know it has a backup on disk and it's also transactional what that means is you can queue up a bunch of commands and then you can commit the commands and so let's say for example let's say i load patrick's profile i'm a web server and patrick logs into my server on his computer and uh he goes and like changes his password but then at exactly the same time uh evil patrick who's masquerading as regular patrick is on patrick's phone and changes his password right there on the phone too or changes something else changes his like profile picture it a Hello Kitty picture at exactly the same
它做了一些聪明的缓存。但如果你没命中缓存，你知道它在磁盘上有备份，而且它是事务性的。这意味着你可以排队一堆命令，然后你可以提交这些命令。所以，让我们举个例子，假设我加载了 Patrick 的个人资料，我是一个 Web 服务器，Patrick 在他的电脑上登录了我的服务器，嗯，他去修改了他的密码，但就在同一时间，嗯，冒充普通 Patrick 的邪恶 Patrick 在 Patrick 的手机上，也在手机上修改了他的密码，或者修改了其他东西，修改了他的个人资料图片，一张 Hello Kitty 图片，就在同一
time. That can cause issues. You could end up saving two things twice, and one can collide and things like that. So you need to support transactions to deal with things like that. So the thing that comes in second, the transaction will fail. It'll say, hey, something weird has happened. This data has been modified you need to take a look at this and sort this out so it handles like the very basics of what
时间。这可能会导致问题。你最终可能会保存两次，一个可能会冲突之类的。所以你需要支持事务来处理这类事情。所以第二个进来的事务会失败。它会说，嘿，发生了奇怪的事情。这个数据已经被修改了，你需要看一看并解决这个问题。所以它处理了你所需要的
you need to have a have a what's called an ACID compliant database and ACID I don't remember do you know what it stands for Patrick it's like atomic consistency isolation durability ah there you go perfect so yeah so you want that so uh berkeley db has a bunch of bindings like c c++ um you know i think there's a python binding actually i think it's part of python uh actually now um so if you're using java now java already has a really nice collections framework right like java has map and you know hash map tree map linked list array list all these cool things and since java already has all this infrastructure there's something called jdBM, which basically what it does is it gives you a map, like a Java map, but that map is backed to disk. So in other words, you could write your program and have everything in memory, like all your usernames and passwords and all that in memory. And then once your program gets more mature and you say, okay, I want to to deploy this you can just replace the new hash
最基本的东西，也就是所谓的 ACID 兼容数据库。ACID，我不记得了，你知道它代表什么吗，Patrick？它是原子性、一致性、隔离性、持久性。啊，你说对了，完美。所以，是啊，所以你想要那个。所以，嗯，Berkeley DB 有一堆绑定，比如 C、C++，嗯，我想实际上有一个 Python 绑定，我想它是 Python 的一部分，嗯，实际上现在……所以如果你现在使用 Java，Java 已经有一个非常好的集合框架了，对吧？比如 Java 有 Map，你知道 HashMap、TreeMap、LinkedList、ArrayList，所有这些很酷的东西。既然 Java 已经有了所有这些基础设施，有一种东西叫 JDBM，它基本上所做的是给你一个 Map，就像一个 Java Map，但那个 Map 是备份到磁盘的。换句话说，你可以编写你的程序，把所有东西都放在内存里，比如你所有的用户名和密码，所有这些都在内存里。然后一旦你的程序变得更成熟，你说，好吧，我想部署这个，你可以直接替换新的 HashMap
map with jdbm3 hash map and it'll just deal with everything under the hood so it'll put things to disk i need to go to disk it'll load things from disk etc etc and actually berkeley db is the most popular database because it's installed like multiple times on everyone's machine like even if you run windows windows actually uses berkeley db for a number of things oh wow so this doesn't handle over the network though right like this is just for like local persistence to disk right that's right and the other thing is um it doesn't handle multi-processor although now there are some versions that are starting to get into that okay but for the most part it's you know if you have a single program it could be multi-threaded
为 JDBM3 HashMap，它就会在底层处理一切。所以它会把东西放到磁盘上，我需要去磁盘，它会从磁盘加载东西等等等等。而且实际上 Berkeley DB 是最流行的数据库，因为它在每个人的机器上被安装了多次，即使你运行 Windows，Windows 实际上也为了很多事情使用 Berkeley DB。哦，哇。所以这个不处理网络，对吧？这只是为了像本地持久化到磁盘，对吧？没错。另一件事是，嗯，它不处理多处理器，尽管现在有一些版本开始涉及那个了。好吧，但大部分情况下，你知道，如果你有一个单一程序，它可以是多线程的
and i think we talked about this but uh just to recap really quick multi-threaded means you have you know a bunch of different threads that could all be doing different things but they're all sharing the same memory versus multi-process each one is a completely different program and so uh berkeley db and jdbm don't support multi-process yet but they support multi-threaded so nice yeah so i mean unless you're you know a lot of websites use mysql um but really unless you're like some kind of powerhouse, you'd be totally fine. Like if you're doing your own coding, you'd be totally fine using something like this. And you'd save yourself a ton of time.
我想我们谈过这个，但嗯，只是快速回顾一下，多线程意味着你拥有，你知道，一堆不同的线程，它们都可以做不同的事情，但它们都共享相同的内存。而多进程，每一个都是一个完全不同的程序。所以，嗯，Berkeley DB 和 JDBM 还不支持多进程，但它们支持多线程。所以不错。是啊，我的意思是，除非你是，你知道，很多网站使用 MySQL，但真的，除非你是某种强力用户，否则你会完全没问题的。就像如果你在做自己的编码，使用这样的东西你会完全没问题的。而且你会节省大量时间。
And then I think if you use like a key value pattern like that, right? So if you can reduce it to something simple like that, then I think it would be easy to move it over to network. Like I think Redis and other databases are kind of the same idea but for network connected things so if you wanted to add in sharing with other people if you're using this key value mentality there are other solutions that will take you to the next step that's right there's couch db redis there's um h base there's a ton of them and we should maybe talk about dedicate some time to that you know in the future because those are actually really really interesting right all right um yeah well what about your tool of the bi-week nothing nearly so enterprisey or program i don't know anyways audacity so i've
然后我想如果你使用像那样的键值模式，对吧？所以如果你能把它简化成那样简单的东西，那么我想把它移动到网络上会很容易。就像我想 Redis 和其他数据库也是同样的想法，但针对网络连接的事物。所以如果你想增加与其他人的共享，如果你使用这种键值思维，还有其他解决方案会带你进入下一步。没错，有 CouchDB、Redis，有嗯 HBase，有一大堆。我们也许应该谈谈，在未来专门花点时间讨论那个，因为那些实际上真的真的很有趣。对。好吧，嗯，是啊，那么你的双周工具呢？没什么那么企业化或程序化的。我不知道，反正，Audacity。所以我
i've thought well for sure we've talked about audacity before and maybe we have and maybe my show notes are lacking but i looked through all the show notes and i couldn't find it wow and i decided we needed to talk about it because it is what you are listening through us the power by which you are listening to us now definitely so that's what we use to record this podcast and edit it and you know it before to do this kind of thing you used to have to buy expensive software. And then when Audacity came around, it really changed all of that. So you can record, you can clean up, you can edit, you can mix multiple tracks together. If we had cool sound effects, we would be able to put them in.
我想，嗯，我们肯定之前谈过 Audacity，也许我们谈过，也许我的节目笔记缺失了，但我浏览了所有的节目笔记，我找不到它。哇，我决定我们需要谈谈它，因为它是你现在听我们说话的媒介，你现在听我们说话的力量。绝对是。所以这就是我们用来录制这个播客并编辑它的工具，你知道，以前要做这种事情，你必须购买昂贵的软件。然后当 Audacity 出现时，它真的改变了这一切。所以你可以录音，你可以清理，你可以编辑，你可以混合多个轨道。如果我们有很酷的音效，我们就能把它们放进去。
For right now, we use it to do our intros and our outros. All that kind of stuff we do using Audacity. And it's amazing and it's free. And it's open source it's free and it's open source yeah i remember when i used to use adobe premiere and then i think even before that i used something called cool edit or maybe that was after but yeah i mean at some point i use these programs they cost like hundreds of dollars and it was just it's just like they're very slow and clunky and um you know audacity works on windows linux macacity works on Windows, Linux, Mac. It works on anything. Really nice interface.
目前，我们用它来做我们的片头和片尾。所有这些事情我们都用 Audacity 做。它很神奇，而且它是免费的。它是开源的，它是免费的，它是开源的。是啊，我记得我以前用 Adobe Premiere，然后我想甚至在那之前，我用过一个叫 Cool Edit 的东西，或者也许那是之后，但是啊，我的意思是，在某个时候，我使用这些程序，它们花费数百美元，而且它只是……它们非常缓慢和笨重，而且，嗯，你知道，Audacity 在 Windows、Linux、Mac 上运行。它在任何东西上都能运行。非常好的界面。
Let's you do all the, like, they added all the polish, you know. Like, for example, you know, I'm on my headphones, and there's an option so that it won't use your speakers, like won't use your microphone that's hooked up to your computer if you have the headphones plugged in and things like that. Yep. Very nice. Very powerful.
让你做所有的，比如，他们添加了所有的润色，你知道。比如，你知道，我戴着耳机，有一个选项，这样它就不会使用你的扬声器，比如如果你插上了耳机，它就不会使用连接到你电脑的麦克风之类的。是的。非常好。非常强大。
And if you don't know about it and you want to do any sort of audio editing that's where you should go yeah totally totally so all right let's talk about lua lua now how similar is lua to a luau very similar it's because i like luau's i love luau's the only thing sometimes like like you see that pig what is that called when they have the pig with the apple in its mouth yeah yeah suckling suckling pig that's right yeah the suckling pig i think lua core dumps a lot more than the suckling pig but that might be because the pig is dead oh okay we might have lost people from our trying to be punny but yeah so lua originated in brazil it actually has an interesting history at some point brazil
如果你不知道它，并且你想做任何形式的音频编辑，那就是你应该去的地方。是啊，完全，完全。所以，好吧，让我们谈谈 Lua。Lua，现在 Lua 和 Luau 有多相似？非常相似。这是因为我喜欢 Luau，我爱 Luau。唯一的事情有时，像……就像你看到那只猪，当他们有那只嘴里叼着苹果的猪时，那叫什么？是啊，是啊，乳猪，乳猪，没错。是啊，乳猪。我想 Lua 的核心转储比乳猪多得多，但这可能是因为猪已经死了。哦，好吧，我们可能会因为试图讲双关语而失去听众。但是啊，所以 Lua 起源于巴西，它实际上有一段有趣的历史。在某个时候，巴西
actually had a like some kind of law where they weren't allowed you weren't allowed to import source code it's like the craziest thing i've ever heard of yeah it's like almost like a trade embargo of sorts yeah we want our country to stay behind in technology maybe that's why so many of them use orchid oh man uh but yeah so so there's so there's uh so for people who don't know uh orchid is a social network sort of like predecessor to facebook or any of these it was like even earlier than friendster and for some reason it's like massive adoption in brazil but that's it yeah although they said it's not anymore facebook surpassed or popularity in brazil oh really well it's about time uh but anyway so uh yeah it started off in bra Brazil as a need to sort of create embeddable language.
实际上有一条法律，规定你不允许进口源代码。这是我听过的最疯狂的事情。是啊，这几乎就像某种贸易禁运。是啊，我们希望我们的国家在技术上保持落后，也许这就是为什么他们那么多人使用 Orkut。天哪，嗯，但是啊，所以……所以有……所以对于不知道的人，嗯，Orkut 是一个社交网络，类似于 Facebook 或任何这些的前身。它甚至比 Friendster 更早，而且由于某种原因，它在巴西被大规模采用，但仅此而已。是啊，尽管他们说现在不是了，Facebook 在巴西的受欢迎程度超过了 Orkut。哦，真的吗？好吧，是时候了。但无论如何，所以，嗯，是啊，它在巴西开始，作为一种创建可嵌入语言的需求。
But, you know, actually, although it sort of sounds like something, you know, it was created because there was no alternatives in Brazil. The reality is it's a fantastic embeddable language. And, you know, at the time it was created, the only language even remotely, you know, similar in its ability to sort of integrate other languages is TCL or Tickle as some people call it we're talking like 1993 yeah this has been around for a long time and I don't know
但是，你知道，实际上，虽然它听起来像某种东西，你知道，它是被创造出来的，因为在巴西没有替代品。现实是它是一种出色的可嵌入语言。而且，你知道，在它被创造的时候，唯一一种在集成其他语言的能力上甚至有点相似的语言是 TCL，或者有些人称之为 Tickle。我们说的是 1993 年。是啊，这已经存在很长时间了，我不知道
I've used Tickle a couple of times like very very light usage and I couldn't stand it is that how you say it? I don't think I've ever heard it said that way before I always just called it Tcl yeah i've heard both okay let's see if you all dig it up it's okay it doesn't matter but yeah i mean lua is it goes way back and it's been around for a while and the interesting thing about it is that a lot of those things that used to exist around you know aren't really around anymore um but there are certain artifacts we have today
我用过几次 Tickle，非常非常轻度的使用，我受不了它。那是你说的那个发音吗？我想我从来没听过那样说。我一直只叫它 Tcl。是啊，我两种都听过。好吧，让我们看看你们是否能把它挖出来，没关系，它不重要。但是啊，我的意思是 Lua，它追溯到很久以前，而且已经存在一段时间了。有趣的是，很多过去存在的东西，你知道，现在已经不存在了，嗯，但今天有一些人工制品
that are just from older than you would imagine. Like even just the Bash shell and Bash scripting and scripting on Linux or Unix type terminals. These things are things that have been around for a while and they haven't changed much. And even things like Java. When did Java first release? We did not do research.
比你想象的要古老。就像仅仅是 Bash shell 和 Bash 脚本，以及在 Linux 或 Unix 类型终端上的脚本。这些东西已经存在一段时间了，而且它们没有太大变化。甚至像 Java 这样的东西。Java 是什么时候首次发布的？我们没有做研究。
I was in high school, so it must have been like 98 or 97. Yeah, so I mean, you're talking about even older than that. It's saying 1995 was when it was first released. So Lua was two years predating even Java, which is kind of crazy. Yeah, yeah, Lua's around forever. And it's still relevant today. Yeah, totally. So it is kind of crazy. Yeah, yeah. Lua's around forever. And it's still relevant today. Yeah, totally. So it is Tickle, according to Wikipedia.
我当时在上高中，所以它一定是在 98 或 97 年左右。是啊，所以我的意思是，你谈论的甚至比那更早。它说是 1995 年首次发布的。所以 Lua 比 Java 早两年，这有点疯狂。是啊，是啊，Lua 永远存在。而且它今天仍然相关。是啊，完全。所以它确实有点疯狂。是啊，是啊，Lua 永远存在。而且它今天仍然相关。是啊，完全。所以根据维基百科，它是 Tickle。
I will correct my language from henceforth. But yeah, so Lua is interpreted. So it's like Python where it's compiled, but it could be compiled at runtime. So it has that interpreted feel. So it's like kind of transp could be compiled at runtime so you know it has that it's like kind of transparently compiled yeah exactly so you can create lua i think it's called lua c files just like the pyc files in python and then you don't have to do the compiling um save yourself a little bit of processor but uh yeah for the most part everyone just uses the source files and treats as an interpreter it's similar to python as dynamic typing but one thing it's very different in lua everything is based on tables and meta tables and you know lists has dictionaries has um uh classes so a class
我从今以后会纠正我的语言。但是啊，所以 Lua 是解释型的。所以它就像 Python，它是编译的，但它可以在运行时编译。所以它有那种解释的感觉。所以它就像有点……可以在运行时编译，所以你知道它有那种……它就像有点透明地编译。是啊，完全。所以你可以创建 Lua，我想它叫 Lua C 文件，就像 Python 中的 pyc 文件，然后你就不必进行编译了，嗯，为你自己节省一点处理器，但嗯，是啊，大部分情况下，每个人只是使用源文件并将其视为解释器。它类似于 Python，具有动态类型，但有一点非常不同，在 Lua 中，一切都基于表和元表，而且你知道，列表有字典，有嗯……类。所以一个类
in python is uh has that sort of dictionary meta information and then has the class assignment stuff i think does python have anything else uh core structures i think that's all of them i mean there's like sets but sets are based on lists. And then it has the usuals like string and number and all that. In Lua, all you have are tables and meta tables, which is something we'll talk about in a bit. But with just tables and the primitive data types, you can actually create a wide array of things in Lua.
在 Python 中，嗯，有那种字典元信息，然后有类赋值的东西。我想 Python 还有其他东西吗？核心结构，我想这就是全部了。我的意思是，有集合之类的，但集合是基于列表的。然后它有通常的，比如字符串和数字等等。在 Lua 中，你拥有的只有表和元表，这是我们稍后会谈论的东西。但仅用表和原始数据类型，你实际上可以在 Lua 中创建各种各样的东西。
Should we try to do an example of MetaTable? I think I can try. I'll try and pull this off. Okay. So there are features in all of these languages which people tend to get excited about or talk in depth about on the internet, but that doesn't mean they...
我们应该尝试做一个元表的例子吗？我想我可以试试。我会试着完成这个。好吧。所以所有这些语言中都有一些特性，人们倾向于在互联网上感到兴奋或深入讨论，但这并不意味着它们……
And I don't know if this is the case with Lua or not i i personally haven't used the meta tables part of lua but i mean just before you go into the explanation jason not to interrupt you uh totally uh yeah so i mean like there's even like we talked about in c++ about meta programming you know um this is something that gets talked about a lot because it's kind of cool and nifty and whiz bang um but that doesn't mean that the majority of code even uses it or ever thinks about it or ever even comes close to thinking about it like um but it might still be talked about on the internet and there's something that as programmers we need to do a little bit of due diligence to avoid and again i don't know that this applies in this specific case but just because something is discussed on the internet or
我不知道 Lua 是否也是这种情况，我个人没有使用过 Lua 的元表部分，但我的意思是，在你进行解释之前，Jason，不是要打断你，嗯，完全，嗯，是啊，我的意思是，甚至像我们在 C++ 中谈论的元编程，你知道，嗯，这是人们谈论很多的东西，因为它很酷、很时髦、很棒，但这并不意味着大多数代码甚至使用它，或者曾经考虑过它，或者甚至接近考虑过它。就像，嗯，但它可能仍然在互联网上被谈论，这是我们作为程序员需要做一点尽职调查以避免的事情。再说一次，我不知道这是否适用于这个特定案例，但仅仅因为某事在互联网上被讨论或
talked about doesn't mean it's something that you need to have in your program. Yeah, totally. I mean, I wrote Lua for a little over a year as a scripting language to another program that our company is working on. But, yeah, we didn't use metatables or anything fancy like that. And to Patrick's point, most of the time in Lua, you're just taking advantage of how Lua can work with other programs. And so you're usually doing the fancy thing in that other program. So sorry, metatables.
谈论，并不意味着它是你需要放入程序中的东西。是啊，完全。我的意思是，我写了一年多的 Lua，作为我们公司正在开发的另一个程序的脚本语言。但是，是啊，我们没有使用元表或任何像那样的花哨东西。而且对于 Patrick 的观点，大多数时候在 Lua 中，你只是利用 Lua 如何与其他程序一起工作。所以你通常在那个其他程序中做花哨的事情。所以抱歉，元表。
Yeah, I'll give metatables a shot. So first let's talk about tables briefly. A table in Lua is a hash table. It's an associative array. So, for example, if you want in lua you can say you know you can create a new table like my table equals you know open brace close brace and then you could say like my table uh key sunday equals zero and my table monday is one tuesday is two wednesday is three etc etc and so then later on, you could say, well, what is Wednesday? And it'll tell you three for the third day of the week, right?
是啊，我会试一下元表。所以首先让我们简要谈谈表。Lua 中的表是一个哈希表。它是一个关联数组。所以，例如，如果你想在 Lua 中，你可以说，你知道，你可以创建一个新表，比如 my table 等于，你知道，左大括号，右大括号，然后你可以说，比如 my table，键 Sunday 等于 0，my table Monday 是 1，Tuesday 是 2，Wednesday 是 3，等等等等。所以稍后，你可以说，好吧，Wednesday 是什么？它会告诉你 3，一周的第三天，对吧？
Or I guess the fourth day of the week is zero-based. But basically, you know, it's an associative race, so it just uses the equals operation for whatever type it's using. So you could have a table with tables in's using so you could have a table with tables in it or you could have a table that maps numbers to strings it doesn't matter right because it'll just uh it knows how to compare if two things are equal and so it can just hash anything so wait so so i mean this is the second time we've kind of brought this up but maybe a quick explanation of hash tables just like the idea of hashing is just taking one thing,
或者我猜一周的第四天是基于 0 的。但基本上，你知道，它是关联数组，所以它只是对它使用的任何类型使用等于操作。所以你可以有一个包含表的表，或者你可以有一个将数字映射到字符串的表，这没关系，对吧？因为它只是……它知道如果两个东西相等如何比较，所以它可以哈希任何东西。所以等等，所以……我的意思是这是我们第二次提到这个，但也许快速解释一下哈希表，就像哈希的想法只是获取一个东西，
running some sort of function on it, and producing a number. So like if you take one number, you might multiply it by 10. And that's your hashing function. That's not a very good hashing function. And then typically like the simplest way to think about a hash table is just an array. So let's say you have an array
对它运行某种函数，并产生一个数字。所以就像如果你取一个数字，你可能会把它乘以 10。这就是你的哈希函数。那不是一个很好的哈希函数。然后通常，就像思考哈希表的最简单方法就是数组。所以让我们说你有一个数组
that's size 10. And you want to store things in it that aren't necessarily obvious that it should be an array. So let's say you have an array that size 10 and you want to store things in it that aren't necessarily obvious, you know, that it should be an array. So like to Jason's point, if you want to store the day of the week Sunday somewhere in there, where should Sunday go? Well, you could take the letters of Sunday and like add the ASCII value of each of the letters, you know, modulus. So divide that and take the remainder of 10 and say like, that's the index in the array I'm going to use to store anything that's Sunday. Or like Jason's saying, you can use it kind of like more like maybe an enumeration where Sunday is kind of like the zeroth object or store zero in it. So when you look it up later in the table, you can pull out the number zero
大小为 10。你想在里面存储不一定显而易见应该是数组的东西。所以让我们说你有一个大小为 10 的数组，你想在里面存储不一定显而易见，你知道，应该是数组的东西。所以就像 Jason 的观点，如果你想在某个地方存储星期几 Sunday，Sunday 应该去哪里？好吧，你可以取 Sunday 的字母，比如加上每个字母的 ASCII 值，你知道，模数。所以除以那个并取 10 的余数，并说，这就是我将用来存储任何是 Sunday 的东西的数组索引。或者像 Jason 说的，你可以把它用得更像，也许是一个枚举，其中 Sunday 就像第 0 个对象，或者在里面存储 0。所以当你稍后在表中查找它时，你可以取出数字 0
and you know that that is the value Sunday should have. Yeah, totally. And so there's something in hash tables called collision so let's say for example let's say you did what patrick was saying where you add up all the ascii values and divide in modulus 10 and just coincidentally let's just say sunday and wednesday when you did that they both had eight that doesn't mean that wednesday is going to replace sunday what happens with the hash table is when it goes to insert Wednesday, it'll see, oh, Sunday is already in this table, but Sunday and Wednesday are two different things. So then it'll do like what's called a deep compare. So first it'll
并且你知道那就是 Sunday 应该有的值。是啊，完全。所以哈希表中有一种东西叫冲突。所以让我们举个例子，让我们说你做了 Patrick 所说的，你把所有的 ASCII 值加起来并除以 10 取模，巧合的是，让我们假设 Sunday 和 Wednesday 当你这样做时，它们都是 8。这并不意味着 Wednesday 要取代 Sunday。哈希表发生的情况是，当它去插入 Wednesday 时，它会看到，哦，Sunday 已经在表中了，但 Sunday 和 Wednesday 是两件不同的事情。所以它会做所谓的深度比较。所以首先它会
compare just the hashing, the hash function. And if there's a collision, it'll do a deep compare and say, is this the same item? Should I replace it? If it's not, then it'll, a deep compare and say is this the same item should i replace it um if it's not then it'll there's many different things it can do then but uh um but yeah basically a hash table is a way to get really fast lookup and entry of items and the reason why is because you don't have to search through the whole array or whole you know storage because you know exactly where to go because of this hashing function. Right, and you don't have to sort either or try and put things in order. But it doesn't help you.
比较哈希，哈希函数。如果发生冲突，它会进行深度比较并说，这是同一个项目吗？我应该替换它吗？如果不是，那么它会……深度比较并说这是同一个项目吗？我应该替换它吗？嗯，如果不是，那么它会……有很多不同的事情它可以做，但嗯……但是啊，基本上哈希表是一种获得非常快速的项目查找和输入的方法。原因是因为你不必搜索整个数组或整个，你知道，存储，因为你知道由于这个哈希函数，确切地去哪里。对，而且你也不必排序或尝试把东西按顺序排列。但这帮不了你。
If you do need a sorted list, a hash table won't help you. That's right. So, yeah, so tables. So in Lua, let's say you have this table with days of the week, Sunday, Monday, Tuesday, etc but you want the table to do something special if it gets a string it never saw before this is sort of a weird
如果你确实需要一个排序列表，哈希表帮不了你。没错。所以，是啊，所以表。所以在 Lua 中，假设你有这个包含一周中几天的表，Sunday、Monday、Tuesday 等等，但你想要表在它遇到以前没见过的字符串时做一些特别的事情。这是一个有点奇怪的
example coming up with on the fly here but let's say you had a table where if someone, let's say this is some kind of like cache so it's a table to get the day of the week, but it's not always accurate. So for example, let's say the table just has English days of the week. So as the keys in the table would be Sunday,
例子，临时想出来的，但让我们说你有一个表，如果有人，让我们说这是一种缓存，所以它是一个获取星期几的表，但它并不总是准确的。所以例如，让我们说表里只有英语的星期几。所以作为表中的键，将是 Sunday，
so Sunday would map to zero, Monday would map to one, Tuesday would map to two, et cetera, et cetera. But then you could end up getting... Domingo. Yeah, Domingo. Thank you. to two etc etc but then you could end up getting uh domingo yeah domingo thank you i couldn't remember any any day for any language okay so let's say you get domingo what you could do in lua is you can create a meta table and what the meta table do is if there isn't a key in the table but you try to look it up anyways like you're trying to look up domingo but it's not in the table, but you try to look it up anyways, like you're trying to look up Domingo, but it's not in the table, it could fall back on the meta table. And the meta table might do something like go to some database that has like all the days of the week for all the foreign languages. So by using this meta table concept, you know, if you want Sunday, you get it really quick.
所以 Sunday 会映射到 0，Monday 会映射到 1，Tuesday 会映射到 2，等等等等。但后来你最终可能会得到……Domingo。是啊，Domingo。谢谢。到 2 等等等等，但后来你最终可能会得到，嗯，Domingo。是啊，Domingo。谢谢，我记不起任何语言的任何一天了。好吧，所以让我们说你得到了 Domingo，你可以在 Lua 中做的是你可以创建一个元表，元表的作用是，如果表中没有键，但你无论如何都要查找它，就像你试图查找 Domingo，但它不在表中，但你无论如何都要查找它，就像你试图查找 Domingo，但它不在表中，它可以回退到元表。而元表可能会做一些事情，比如去某个拥有所有外语星期几的数据库。所以通过使用这个元表概念，你知道，如果你想要 Sunday，你很快就能得到它。
You know, it's in the table,'s in memory but if you want domingo which maybe you don't want that often let's say because the majority of your business is in the u.s right now but occasionally there's a domingo that comes across um then you want to have this meta table that captures that hits the database and then returns you know whatever what is that six or something is domingo saturday or sunday uh it's sunday oh sunday because it returns zero for that so that's what meta tables that you do and if you look on wikipedia there's some pretty clever examples there's one where they uh they do the fibonacci sequence, which for people who don't know, it's, what is it, n plus n minus. The sum of the two digits of the, or the two prior entries in the series.
你知道，它在表中，在内存中，但如果你想要 Domingo，也许你并不经常想要它，让我们说，因为你目前大部分业务都在美国，但偶尔会有一个 Domingo 出现，嗯，那么你想要有这个元表来捕获它，命中数据库，然后返回，你知道，无论是什么，是 6 还是什么，Domingo 是周六还是周日？是周日。哦，周日，因为它返回 0。所以这就是元表让你做的。如果你看维基百科，有一些非常聪明的例子，有一个例子是他们做斐波那契数列，对于不知道的人，它是，它是什么，n 加 n 减。序列中前两个条目的总和。
Right. So, for example, like, you know, the Fibonacci number of 1 is 1, and 2 is 1. But then 3 is going to be f of 1 plus f of 2, which is 2. And the Fibonacci sequence of 4 is going to be f of 2 plus f of 3, which is 3. So they were able to use the metatables to say, okay, I'll create a table, and 1 is 1 and 2 is 1. And then I create a metatable where if they want anything besides 1 or 2, it's the table entry of n minus 2 plus the table of entry of n minus 1. And so that all kind
对。所以，举个例子，你知道，斐波那契数列的第1项是1，第2项是1。但第3项就是f(1)加f(2)，也就是2。而斐波那契数列的第4项就是f(2)加f(3)，也就是3。所以他们能够利用元表（metatables）来说，好的，我创建一个表，1对应1，2对应1。然后我创建一个元表，如果他们想要除了1或2以外的任何值，它就是表项n减2加上表项n减1。所以这一切都
of recurs backwards and Lua is smart about caching. So let's say something happens where all of a sudden you have an influx of Spanish speaking people hitting your website, and everyone wants Domingo all of a sudden, Lua will actually cache that value. So you won't have to just keep hitting the database. So it's clever about that. This is also called memoization. When you do like... Well, memoization is more with respect to recursion, but if you do these kind of things
以递归方式向后回溯，而且Lua在缓存方面很聪明。所以假设发生了一些情况，突然有一大批讲西班牙语的人访问你的网站，每个人都突然想要Domingo，Lua实际上会缓存该值。所以你就不必一直去查询数据库。所以它在这方面很聪明。这也被称为记忆化（memoization）。当你做类似……嗯，记忆化更多是关于递归的，但如果你做这些事情
where you cache data in a table, in a hash table, so you don't have to keep calling a function, Lua will do that for you. It's pretty clever. So it's cool because in some ways you're able to just use a table that in theory has infinitely many entries in it, has all of the Fibonacci sequence in it. But then only when you actually try to use some entry of the Fibonacci sequence does it actually go and figure out what that number should be. Right. This is also called lazy, like either lazy loading or in this case lazy calculations. It only calculates what it needs to.
当你把数据缓存在一个表里，在一个哈希表里，这样你就不必一直调用函数，Lua会为你做这件事。这很聪明。所以这很酷，因为在某些方面，你能够只使用一个理论上拥有无限多条目的表，它拥有整个斐波那契数列。但只有当你真正尝试使用斐波那契数列的某个条目时，它才会去计算那个数字应该是多少。对吧。这也被称为惰性，比如惰性加载，或者在这种情况下是惰性计算。它只计算它需要的部分。
That's right. That's right. Interesting. So we kind of hinted at some of the strengths of Lua that we already mentioned that it was used as like a scripting language. And it's kind of used as a scripting language I guess because it works so well with C and C++ it's really easy to embed it and you said you've worked with it this way before? Yeah definitely so Lua was designed to integrate with with C specifically but later on with c++ and so you know just to put this like in just a contrast um let's say you want to embed like python for example well you have to use this like really
没错。没错。很有趣。所以我们提到了Lua的一些优势，我们已经提到它被用作脚本语言。我想它之所以被用作脚本语言，是因为它与C和C++配合得非常好，嵌入它非常容易，你说过你以前这样用过？是的，绝对是这样。所以Lua的设计初衷就是为了与C集成，特别是后来与C++集成，所以你知道，为了做一个对比，嗯，假设你想嵌入像Python这样的语言，好吧，你必须使用这种非常
clunky like python c api and uh like everything is kind of based on these functions and you have to like convert like python oh Oh, I forgot the... So there's calling C from Python, and then there's scripting events in C with Python. Right, yeah. And so both of those get complicated because you have to transmute the types. So in Python, you have lists, you have dictionaries,
笨拙的Python C API，而且一切都基于这些函数，你必须转换像Python……哦，我忘了……所以有从Python调用C，还有用Python在C中编写脚本事件。对，没错。所以这两者都变得很复杂，因为你必须转换类型。所以在Python中，你有列表，你有字典，
you have all these different types, right, as we talked about at the beginning. And each of those, you have dictionaries, you have all these different types, right? As we talked about at the beginning. And each of those, you have to create some kind of analog on the C or C++ side, or you have to create some kind of like accessors. So you have to be able to say like, oh, this is a list in Python, so I want to get the fourth element in this list in my C++ program. Or I have this C++ array, I want Python to think of this as a list, you know, and this kind of stuff ends up becoming like,
你有所有这些不同的类型，对吧，正如我们在开头所讨论的那样。对于每一个，你都必须在C或C++端创建某种模拟，或者你必须创建某种访问器。所以你必须能够说，哦，这是Python中的一个列表，所以我想在我的C++程序中获取这个列表的第四个元素。或者我有这个C++数组，我想让Python把它看作一个列表，你知道，这种事情最终会变得像，
no matter how you do it, ends up becoming really clunky. Lua, you know, it's kind of a double-edged sword. Like it only has tables, but on the plus side, it only has tables, right? Which map exactly to C++, you know, hash maps. So it makes it very easy to integrate++ hash maps. So it makes it very easy to integrate the two languages. And even easier because
无论你怎么做，最终都会变得非常笨拙。Lua，你知道，这是一种双刃剑。它只有表，但好的一面是，它只有表，对吧？这与C++的哈希映射完全对应。所以这使得集成这两种语言变得非常容易。而且更容易，因为
people have, since so many people are doing this with Lua, or embedding it, they've created some amazingly streamlined libraries to make this happen. So one is LuaBind, which I used briefly. But the second one I'm more familiar with is called Diluculum, which I used briefly, but the second one I'm more familiar with is called
人们，因为有很多人在用Lua做这件事，或者嵌入它，他们已经创建了一些非常精简的库来实现这一点。所以一个是LuaBind，我简短地用过。但第二个我更熟悉，叫Diluculum，我简短地用过，但第二个我更熟悉的是叫
Diluculum, which I think it's some African word or something, but we have a link in the show notes so you guys can look it up. But basically it's for C++ and it has a thing that maps Lua tables, actually anything in Lua to the analog in C++++ and sort of does it all transparently so you can just say hey you know go to the lua world and get me this variable and even like on the other side in your lua program you can say hey go to the c++ world and get me this variable and it does it all like very transparently nice yeah it's pretty awesome so because of that strength you can think like
Diluculum，我想这可能是一个非洲词汇之类的，但我们在节目笔记中有一个链接，你们可以去查一下。但基本上它是为C++准备的，它有一个东西可以将Lua表，实际上是Lua中的任何东西映射到C++中的模拟对象，并且以透明的方式完成所有这些，所以你可以直接说，嘿，你知道，去Lua世界帮我获取这个变量，甚至在你的Lua程序的另一端，你可以说，嘿，去C++世界帮我获取这个变量，它非常透明地完成了所有这些，很好，是的，这太棒了，所以因为这个优势，你可以想到
anywhere you'd want to script something so things you might want to script like often you hear this in like video games so video games want to have some scripting done where you control what happens when a player swings a sword and hits somebody you know what like what happens you can script that event like i want to decrease damage by 10 and i want to you know trigger effect magic lightning bolts you know onto the screen and these kinds of things you can imagine like through play testing and stuff you might want to tweak those but you don't have to go in and actually like you know edit the code or have to even know what the code means you might want to have other people be able to make those changes and so scripting languages just provide that flexibility to you.
任何你想编写脚本的地方，所以你可能想编写脚本的事情，比如你经常在电子游戏中听到这个，所以电子游戏想要完成一些脚本编写，你可以控制当玩家挥剑击中某人时会发生什么，你知道，会发生什么，你可以编写那个事件的脚本，比如我想减少10点伤害，我想，你知道，触发魔法闪电效果，你知道，在屏幕上，这些事情你可以想象，通过游戏测试之类的，你可能想要调整这些，但你不必进去真正地，你知道，编辑代码，甚至不必知道代码是什么意思，你可能希望其他人能够进行这些更改，所以脚本语言只是为你提供了这种灵活性。
Yeah, exactly. I mean, you know, most of these game studios, the people who are creating the content, they're not programmers. You know, they're just, they're often like game designers who are just sort of like playing with the different variables. Like, oh, if I make magic more powerful, how does that affect the game? And let me play for a few hours on this setting. And they can't afford, even if they did know how to program,
是的，完全正确。我的意思是，你知道，大多数这些游戏工作室，那些创造内容的人，他们不是程序员。你知道，他们通常是游戏设计师，只是在摆弄不同的变量。比如，哦，如果我让魔法更强大，这对游戏有什么影响？让我在这个设置下玩几个小时。他们负担不起，即使他们知道如何编程，
they can't afford to be recompiling code all the time and things like that. They want to just make changes quick. And so Lua sort of gives them that flexibility. Yeah, Lua is also very fast. You know, because it only has tables basically hash tables it doesn't have to do a lot of thinking it doesn't have a lot of complicated instructions
他们负担不起一直重新编译代码之类的事情。他们只想快速做出改变。所以Lua给了他们这种灵活性。是的，Lua也非常快。你知道，因为它基本上只有表，即哈希表，它不需要做太多的思考，它没有很多复杂的指令
or anything like that and so the execution speed is awesome and you can even use Lua on embedded devices and things like that which don't have strong processors and not worry about it yeah so there's some good strengths and weaknesses I think you kind of alluded to the fact that don't have strong processors and not worry about it. Yeah.
之类的东西，所以执行速度非常快，你甚至可以在嵌入式设备上使用Lua，这些设备没有强大的处理器，也不用担心它。是的，所以有一些优点和缺点，我想你提到了这样一个事实，即没有强大的处理器也不用担心。是的。
So there's some good strengths and weaknesses. I think you kind of alluded to the fact that they really only have tables and meta tables. So, I mean, that's a strength that it's very simple that way, but also, like everything, that can be a weakness as well that it doesn't always obvious how to get what you need to get done. Yeah, totally. I mean, people have tried to shoehorn so much into the tables and meta tables. Like someone created like a class-based infrastructure where, you know,
所以有一些优点和缺点。我想你提到了这样一个事实，即他们真的只有表和元表。所以，我的意思是，这是一种优势，它在那种方式上非常简单，但也像所有事物一样，这可能也是一个弱点，即并不总是显而易见如何完成你需要做的事情。是的，完全是这样。我的意思是，人们试图把太多的东西硬塞进表和元表里。比如有人创建了一个基于类的基础设施，你知道，
if you have getters and setters as like items, keys, and the table, but it's really hacky. And then once you start doing things like that, performance sort of goes down the tubes because it's not the language isn't really designed for that it's not really designed for you to hit a meta table every time you want to access a variable and the other the other weakness is that it's just not very fully featured you know i mean no one's taken the time to bind your favorite library to lua chances are you know like I mean if you really like fluid dynamics or you want to use like some kind of physics engine
如果你有getter和setter作为项目、键和表，但这真的很蹩脚。一旦你开始做这样的事情，性能就会一落千丈，因为这种语言并不是真正为那种用途设计的，它并不是真正为你每次想要访问变量时都去访问一个元表而设计的。另一个弱点是它功能不够全面，你知道，我的意思是，没有人花时间把你最喜欢的库绑定到Lua上。很有可能，你知道，我的意思是，如果你真的喜欢流体力学，或者你想使用某种物理引擎
or if you want to do something like some kind of heavy like differential equations or something you know chances are that that hasn't been you know there's no binding for Lua for that and that's mainly because you know Lua is designed to sort of be a supplement to another language. So you're just not going to get the kind of features you get. Like in Python, for example, if you want to just, let's say you're streaming out a bunch of data to disk, and you want that data to be compressed. Well, there's a gzip, you know, library, like part, which is part of the Python
或者如果你想做一些像繁重的微分方程之类的事情，你知道，很有可能还没有，你知道，没有Lua的绑定，这主要是因为，你知道，Lua被设计为另一种语言的补充。所以你不会得到你在其他语言中得到的那种功能。比如在Python中，如果你想，假设你正在将大量数据流式传输到磁盘，并且你希望该数据被压缩。好吧，有一个gzip库，它是Python标准库的一部分
standard library. So there's compression built in, you can say, look, write this to disk and make it compressed. So that doesn't take up as much space. You're not going to find that kind of functionality in Lua. So if you need those kind of bindings, you're going to have to write them yourself, which could be really tedious. Yeah, yeah but there are some libraries it's not to say that it's not fully featured or functional and we have a link here but i mean there's there are libraries for it and you know it's fairly well supported it's not and again being around so long it kind of has to be and it's just one of those things you're gonna have to go in and say this is what i get and not expect that when you find a cool tool that it will have a binding for lua yeah yeah totally yeah i mean to patrick's
标准库。所以内置了压缩功能，你可以说，看，把这个写到磁盘上并压缩它。这样就不会占用太多空间。你在Lua中找不到那种功能。所以如果你需要那种绑定，你必须自己写，这可能非常乏味。是的，是的，但确实有一些库，这并不是说它功能不全或不可用，我们这里有一个链接，但我的意思是，有相关的库，而且你知道，它得到了相当好的支持，它不是，而且再次强调，存在了这么久，它必须是这样，这只是你必须进去说这就是我得到的，不要指望当你找到一个很酷的工具时，它会有Lua绑定。是的，是的，完全是这样。我的意思是，对于帕特里克的
point there's a we post a link we'll post the link on the show notes and there is a ton of there are a ton of uh you know different libraries for lua and things like that so definitely uh i wouldn't shy away from it because of that um but yeah i mean definitely if you have some existing application and you find yourself just constantly recompiling it and changing constants and recompiling it then you probably should just be using lua so the people that use it i mean we talked about it tends to be scripting so world of warcraft uses lua as their scripting engine so um you know other people i know there's some mods and stuff that are written with scripting language in lua also um i use this program to do some photo editing lightroom which is an adobe product that does
观点，我们发布了一个链接，我们会在节目笔记中发布链接，而且有大量的，有大量的，你知道，针对Lua的不同库之类的东西，所以绝对，我不会因为这个而避开它，但是是的，我的意思是，如果你确实有一些现有的应用程序，并且你发现自己一直在重新编译它，更改常量并重新编译它，那么你可能应该使用Lua。所以使用它的人，我的意思是，我们谈到了它往往是脚本编写，所以《魔兽世界》使用Lua作为他们的脚本引擎，所以，你知道，其他人我知道有一些模组之类的东西是用Lua脚本语言编写的，此外，我使用这个程序进行一些照片编辑，Lightroom，这是一个Adobe产品，它做
workflow for taking pictures and editing them and then you know kind of making libraries or catalogs and saving them out. And all the UI in there was scripted in Lua. Yeah, I mean, UI is an obvious choice. So in general, just to talk a little bit about things, like why you need scripting, right? Now, we talked about a couple of the reasons, you know, with the recompiling and things like that. But also, some things like UI specifically is just a pain to write in a, you know, statically typed language like C++. So, for example, let's say, you know, you want to hit a button or a menu item,
拍摄照片和编辑它们的工作流程，然后，你知道，建立库或目录并保存它们。那里的所有UI都是用Lua编写脚本的。是的，我的意思是，UI是一个显而易见的选择。所以总的来说，只是谈论一些事情，比如为什么你需要脚本，对吧？现在，我们谈到了几个原因，你知道，关于重新编译之类的事情。但也有一些事情，比如UI，在像C++这样的静态类型语言中编写简直是一种痛苦。所以，例如，假设，你知道，你想要点击一个按钮或菜单项，
and when you hit that button, you want a function to be called. Well, in C++, to do do that you have to create some kind of interface class it's a virtual class which has some method called you know like perform function and then all of your classes which need to have this function need to inherit from that class and you need to like downcast the class when you pass it into the button and it just you have to go through all these hoops right but if you have an interpreted language like lua which is driving your gui then you can just bind different actions to different buttons and lua doesn't care about the types of the of the you know actions so it doesn't care if like oh this one function was part of a class
当你点击那个按钮时，你想要调用一个函数。好吧，在C++中，要做到这一点，你必须创建一个接口类，它是一个虚拟类，有一个名为，你知道，比如执行函数的方法，然后所有需要这个函数的类都需要从那个类继承，并且当你把它传递给按钮时，你需要向下转换类，你必须经历所有这些障碍，对吧？但如果你有一个像Lua这样的解释型语言来驱动你的GUI，那么你就可以将不同的动作绑定到不同的按钮上，而且Lua不关心动作的类型，所以它不在乎，比如，哦，这个函数是一个类的一部分，
and now like you have to do all sorts of crazy wizardry to get access to that. Lua, you know, because it's a scripting language, it doesn't have any of that overhead. And so it makes it great for doing UI. Yeah. Yeah. So Lua. Yeah. Give it a shot, man.
现在，你知道，你必须做各种疯狂的魔法才能访问它。Lua，你知道，因为它是一种脚本语言，它没有任何那种开销。所以它非常适合做UI。是的。是的。所以Lua。是的，试一试吧，伙计。
Don't write your UI in c++ if you can help it so um on general notes i guess meta notes kind of like meta tables uh anyways um we have gotten some good feedback from people some extra language suggestions some people writing in to tell us that they found tips or tricks that we've mentioned useful. And as always, we appreciate that, you know, we are always glad to be out there and helping people and at least entertaining you, hopefully. Yeah, totally. So if you do have something to say, you could check us out on Google Plus, we have a programming throwdown plus page. And we're pretty good about putting the new episodes linked there. Or, you know, if you have comments you have comments you can of course put them there hopefully positive but uh we're willing to take criticism as well yeah you can always if you have something you don't necessarily want there you can always email us at programmingthrowdown
如果可以的话，不要用C++编写你的UI。所以，关于一般说明，我想是元说明，有点像元表，无论如何，我们从人们那里得到了一些很好的反馈，一些额外的语言建议，一些人写信告诉我们，他们发现我们提到的技巧或窍门很有用。而且一如既往，我们对此表示感谢，你知道，我们总是很高兴能在这里帮助人们，至少能娱乐你们，希望如此。是的，完全是这样。所以如果你有什么想说的，你可以在Google Plus上查看我们，我们有一个Programming Throwdown Plus页面。而且我们很擅长把新剧集的链接放在那里。或者，你知道，如果你有评论，你有评论，你当然可以放在那里，希望是积极的，但我们也愿意接受批评。是的，你总是可以，如果你有什么不一定想放在那里的东西，你总是可以发电子邮件给我们，programmingthrowdown
at gmail.com yeah one interesting thing somebody wrote in and said that uh i guess they can't access the g plus page unless they're unless they have a G Plus account. Is that true? Oh, I don't know. Yeah, to be honest, I haven't tried. We shall try. I thought it was public. I thought there was a public section.
at gmail.com。是的，有一件有趣的事情，有人写信说，我猜他们无法访问G Plus页面，除非他们有一个G Plus账户。这是真的吗？哦，我不知道。是的，老实说，我没试过。我们应该试试。我以为它是公开的。我以为有一个公共部分。
But, yeah, as Patrick was saying, just to reiterate, if you can't access us on G Plus for whatever reason, don't hesitate to shoot an email to programming throw down at gmail.com. Yeah. And I guess other, if you can't see the plus page, you can also check out the blog. Oh,
但是，是的，正如帕特里克所说，重申一下，如果你因为任何原因无法在G Plus上访问我们，请随时发送电子邮件至programmingthrowdown@gmail.com。是的。我想其他，如果你看不到Plus页面，你也可以查看博客。哦，
that's right. Totally throw down.blogspot.com. Yeah. You could follow the blog. We definitely cross post everything on there. Yeah. And so then there's also, you can put comments there and I believe that generate,
没错。Totally throwdown.blogspot.com。是的。你可以关注博客。我们绝对会在上面交叉发布所有内容。是的，所以还有，你可以在那里发表评论，我相信这会生成，
I don't, we don't check that very often, but I think it does actually send us an email when somebody posts a comment there. That's true. So we try to be easy to reach. We're here for you people. Definitely. You know, if you have any – we've had a couple of requests,
我不，我们不经常检查那个，但我认为当有人在那里发表评论时，它确实会给我们发送一封电子邮件。这是真的。所以我们尽量容易联系。我们在这里为你们服务。绝对。你知道，如果你有任何——我们已经有几个请求了，
and we want to fulfill the requests. So definitely Java is going to be coming down the pipe, and Go is going to be coming down the pipe. You're foreshadowing. Now we have a lot to live up to but if there are any other requests uh from the audience don't hesitate we definitely read every one of them and uh you know we uh we have a backlog that we're getting yeah and don't be offended if we don't reply to you or you know whatever we are listening we are taking
我们想满足这些请求。所以Java肯定会有的，Go也肯定会有的。你在预告。现在我们有很多要实现的，但如果观众还有其他请求，请不要犹豫，我们肯定会阅读每一个，而且，你知道，我们有一个积压的工作正在处理。是的，如果我们没有回复你或者你知道什么，不要感到被冒犯，我们正在倾听，我们正在接受
it in um and yep hopefully we'll get there one day yeah yeah i mean if you say you want a language you're gonna get it it just might uh it's just in the pipeline i'm actually surprised i did make up a list and the list is pretty long so there are a lot of languages to go through yeah totally so and then probably it's one of those things where more is there more created than we're talking about like is there at least one created every two weeks oh man there could be. Uh-oh. We might never finish this job, Jason.
它，嗯，是的，希望有一天我们能做到。是的，是的，我的意思是，如果你说你想要一种语言，你就会得到它，它可能只是，它只是在筹备中。我其实很惊讶我确实列了一个清单，而且清单很长，所以有很多语言要讲。是的，完全是这样。所以，然后这可能是那种情况，即创造出来的比我们谈论的更多，比如每两周至少创造一种吗？哦，天哪，可能会有。糟糕。我们可能永远无法完成这项工作，Jason。
Oh, it could go on forever. Now I know how movie critics feel. All right, on that note, that's all I got. Everyone have a good time. All right, see you guys later. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution See you guys later. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
哦，它可能会永远持续下去。现在我知道电影评论家是什么感觉了。好了，说到这里，这就是我所有的内容了。祝大家玩得开心。好的，回头见。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名许可下分发的。回头见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。